good afternoon good afternoon everyone
so can I formally welcome you to our
council meeting on this 29th of January
2024 before we actually go through the
business of the agenda I'm going to ask
the monitoring officer Mrs Sternberg to
once again talk us through the new
technology Mr Sternberg thank you chair
just a very brief reminder because I'm
sure you don't need reminding of how the
mics work just remember to allow a few
seconds for the camera's focus on you
when you press the button it's your turn
to speak can I also also remind you that
you must be in the seat you were
allocated as the cameras are tuned into
that seat with your names on the voting
in order to help you we have put some
cards on the table to show you which
color means which vote and it clearly
shows for is green against is red and
abstain is yellow so obviously if you're
in doubt refer to the
card very good thank you
chair thank you Mr Sternberg so
hopefully we're under no Illusions now
about which way to vote we'll soon
see so um item one then apologies for
absence Mr M first of all we do have a
list of apologies before we go to the
leaders of groups it's easier to say the
ones we have yes thank you chairman uh
we have apologies from councelor s foret
councelor m Foster councel M Emmons uh
councelor C Renwick uh and councelor P
ancliffe thank you chair
are there any other
apologies no thank you so uh item two
Declarations of interests members are
requested to declare the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interest and or other interests not
already on their register of interests
in any items on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
there are four of us that need to
declare an interest for the rold uh item
item seven that's
myself councilors CLE Giller and
moley are there any other declarations
Council
Giller I also wish to give a declaration
with regards to item 14 which is the
paper on the Strategic leaders board in
that I am a member of darbishire County
Council you Council Pickering thank
you is it working now thank you CH from
our group there are four of us myself
councelor Derek Skinner councelor Carol
Lacy and councelor Tony Lacy on item
seven who are residents of tenants of
rickel thank you Council Pickering
Council
cupit thank chair the same interest on
item 13 I think it's 13 that Council
gillet just mentioned in relation to DCC
14 sorry uh and then also on item 11 a
uh the motion from Council whether or uh
because of my role at DCC it's not a
financial interest or anything like that
but because it may come to me for a
decision in future I'm I'm not going to
leave the room but I'm just going to not
vote and not speak on that thank
you councelor
windley yeah I need to declare uh that
I'm a resident of written hold as well
for item seven thank you Council Dale
you the same for item 14 as a member of
d
thank you anybody else is anyone left to
actually debate
anything no other
declarations thank
you so item three then minutes of the
last meeting held on the 27th of
November 2023 that have been circulated
can we have a proposal please that we
accept those thank you councilor Barker
do we have a second thank you Council
Barry so we're rather than going to
voting machines we're going to do this
by acclamation so uh unless there's any
comments about the minutes in terms of
accuracy all those in
favor anyone
against any
abstentions thank you that's
carried item four then Chairman's
announcements those of us involved with
supporting Northeast arire residents
associated with the Armed Forces will
know D
Jeffrey she is a former High Sheriff who
chaired the darbishire Armed Forces
Covenant meetings and was honorary
Colonel of the darbishire army Cadet
forces Diane was made a Dame in the New
Year's honors
list also included in the list is Millie
brigh born in Chesterfield and brought
up in
kilar the Chelsea player
no cheers for Chelsea then the the
Chelsea player won the European
championships in 2022 with England and
Captain the team to the final of the
recent World
Cup Millie has been made an
obbe on behalf of Northeast arire
District Council I congratulate both
recipients on Honors that recognize
their positive contributions to
others put in Brackets muted Applause
there well Jean and I feel privileged to
have finally made it to a publication
featuring heavy
metal yes ringing world the Bell ringers
weekly Global
magazine there's a joke
there this followed our attendance at a
service at Old Brampton Church to Mark
the centinary of the villagers church
bells proceeding meetings were led by
the bishop of Repton and we were invited
to join campanologist in the bell
tower it was a wonderful
experience you too can share the same
when you will be invited to participate
in bell ringing to raise funds for our
charity appeal look out for details in
due
course we also attended the annual
dinner of the Chesterfield and Northeast
darbishire de
Society while members welcome national
news of of the launch of a British sign
language GCSE from September
2025 the society is facing several local
challenges I encourage this Council to
continue its own positive work in
supporting deaf people in Northeast
darbishire
in turn it would be good to see other
authorities understanding the need to
assist the communication requirements of
deaf people in this
County thank you to counselors who
joined us for the burns night last week
it was a splendid
occasion please continue to check your
emails and councel social media for
forthcoming
events as well as having a good time
you'll also be making a difference for
ashgate hospice which serves cancer
patients and their families across north
darbishire
thank you item five leader of the
council's announcements over to council
bar
okay thank you chair uh just on your
announcements uh Martin I'd say that we
definitely can support the uh the death
Charities and stuff I think that's
really important uh and obviously
congratulate Dian Jeffrey and Milly BR
as well thank you for
that
uh I know it's a bit late but I would
like take this opportunity at our first
meeting of this year to wish everyone a
h uh a happy and safe and prosperous
2024 uh from a council perspective 2024
looks like being uh an exciting and
challenging year none more so when it
comes to money and the council finances
as we will discuss later when we come to
the budget debate our finances are in a
better shape than many of our neighbors
but that doesn't mean 2024 will be a
plane sailing or that we won't face some
hard choices it's easy for what appears
to be a stable financial position to
suddenly get out of hand if you take the
eye off the ball into tallics
CH you know what I mean whatever the
cause of the financial problems at the
county and at other authorities we all
know that 14 years of Tory austerity and
the payent underfunding of local
government has been a feature of those
years which is just one reason Reon why
a general election can't come soon
enough so that the country can have a
new government and a fresh
start we should be aware of the possible
knock on effects of the County Council
budget
cuts and what they might have on
districts and buroughs as we Face having
to pick up some of the Fallout and more
importantly we should never forget that
people affected by these latest round of
County Council courts many of whom are
the most vulnerable in society include
many of our residents another major
challenge facing the council are the
proposed changes to the waste collection
service including the possible
requirement to collect food waste on a
weekly basis but on a positive note I
can report that we are developing
proposals for a new Depot to replace the
one at eckington I think we can all
agree the depot is pass its best and is
prone to flooding on a redler basis as
part of that initiative we are
considering establishing a cross party
group
to help shape this project something on
this scale that is so fundamental to the
council services and shouldn't be
politically
contentious uh I would like to thank the
opposition group for the way they
participate in the Senior Management
review that we undertook before
Christmas and I'm also pleased to
announce that work continues on our
pledge to build or acquire more social
houses and to continue modernizing and
insulating our existing homes
we are progressing the scheme at Stone
broom and the houses at Wingfield are
going up fast in fact they put roof on
one this week with the prospect of the
keys to one of the houses being hand
over before the summer such an ambitious
program isn't working isn't without its
own challenges but the council's
relationship with rickel Holmes has
never been better and I am confident we
can deliver Rick N hommes also face the
task of comp complying with new leg
regulatory regime something they must do
with little money whil I will leave
lorine sh to go into that in more detail
later the meeting I can't o
overemphasize the need for us all to be
aware that all housing providers faced
increased scrutiny as they comply with
these regulations and the impact this
will have on Service delivery so I hope
you will take that into account when we
come to the debate and vote on the item
later I want to conclude by mentioning
the results of this year's employee
servy I know Lee were were pleased with
that with a response rate of
61% it is the best we've ever had whilst
this does flag up some issues that we'll
need addressing overall the responses
were very positive with 75% saying that
they feel part of a team and that they
belong at Northeast Gish also 94% of
them understand how their work
contributes to the council success
so I'm proud of our staff of the work
they do for our residents and of their
passion and commitment to Northeast arer
so I'd like to pass on all my thanks to
all those that took part in the survey
and thank everyone for their
contribution to the work of the council
thank you thank you Council Barker so
item six public participation well I can
confirm there are no public questions so
Moving Straight to item seven which is
the medium-term financial
plan um just to members and those that
are still relatively new to council that
we actually take this in two parts so
the first will be the general fund and
then we'll move to the housing revenue
account so those who've declared an
interest can leave at that point so I'm
going to call on the Director of Finance
and resources Jane deic to U give us the
presentation on the general fund
please
just wait for the technology to catch up
there we go that's
it okay thank you again chair uh and
good afternoon everybody councelor ker
is going to present the MTF P2 in a
short while but just before we do that I
just wanted to take a little bit of time
to just run through some of the more
technical aspects of the of the
financial plan for the next four years
um and Loren Shaw from rard homes has
very kindly come along to join us and
he's going to talk specifically about
the impact of the regulation on our
housing revenue account
so oh can't you hear me is that
better that better I'll stand near the
microphone yeah that's better it is on
it is on oh I can hear myself better now
so right
okay so today we're going to have a
quick look at the general fund we're
going to move on to the HRA the housing
revenue account and we're going to look
at the capital programs for both of the
above accounts we're going to look at
the current budget which is the
revisions of the um budget that was
approved last January and we're going to
look at the original budget which is the
legal budget that you're going to
consider today and that's all produced
in the context of a financial plan which
is for the following three years the
following three years isn't a legal
requirement but it's absolutely prudent
to produce a budget in that context so
that's what we're doing today I will
apologize up front this presentation's
largely the same as the one that went to
scrutiny a couple of weeks ago so if you
did see it to scrutiny you're going to
see it again today so apologies for
that so just a little bit of a look at
the economic fiscal and Regulatory
Outlook because this all impacts on the
decisions that we take when we're we're
setting the budget um our inflation
policy mirrors the bank of England's
monetary policy and that's Target to hit
2% during
2025 interest rates also mirror the bank
of England's monetary policy and they're
expected to fall slowly over the next
couple of years to 3% by the middle of
2026 there are some changes to the
social housing regulation which will
here from Lon in a little while and
there's also the um introduction of the
office for local government which is um
a department of local government within
the DLo within Department of leveling up
housing and communities which is why we
call it doog um which is going to
concentrate on performance monitoring
across the piece for local government in
terms of financial impact uh pay
settlements in for next year's budget 3%
and then 2% thereafter that's mirroring
the inflation re policy um and that's a
welcome relief because we had 9% in
2223 and 6 and a half% in 2324 which of
course have been built into the base
contractual spend increases again are
mapping in mapping inflation mirroring
inflation largely um and then we've got
the cost of Regulation which Lorraine
will come on to
shortly so in terms of the national
settlement it's twoyear second year of a
two-year settlement but it's actually a
rollover from 2019 there's been very
very little change to the basic
principles of the settlement since
2019 what it does give is some certainty
for the first two years of the plan and
as you can see there the level of
government grant funding that we're
getting from um um well you can't quite
see it can you because it's blocked off
by by my face which is a bit annoying
but I can tell you that that box there
where it says oh thank you it's 389
thank you for that so you can see we had
970 last year and it's 990 um forecasts
for
2425 and then last week we had an
announcement from the secretary of state
that following the consultation of the
draft national settlement some further
funding is being made available to local
authorities it's mainly for social care
authorities
there are some additional grants for
Rural communities but all councils are
receiving a 1% increase to the funding
guarantee so on the previous slide where
you saw the 3% funding guarantee that's
been increased to 4% for all local
authorities I've only got estimated
figures at the moment they're the ones
that we've calculated we think that's
going to be about £92,000 additional
income for us so that takes the 389 plus
92 the value won't be confirmed until
after the final settlements approved and
been through Parliament in
February
I've stood here for the past four years
and talked about funding reforms and
once again I'm going to talk about
funding reforms again today so we're not
expecting them to be before the general
election now um so the earliest impact
for our budget is likely to be 26 27 the
government are committed to the reforms
they've also committed to transitional
protection this year which is a welcome
addition to the discussions around the
reforms um but what that does do is put
a considerable amount of uncertainty
into the later years of the financial
plan the business rates reset reset
which you've all heard me talk about on
lots of occasions in the past is still
being linked to the funding reforms and
we're still still expecting that to pred
and we're expecting all of those to take
effect from 2627 that's what I've built
into the
mtfp so in terms of the current budget
the budget that you approved last
January we've revised that position um
the shortfall at the time of approval
was 784 that shortfall is now reduced to
3 31 and we'll continue to work through
those efficiencies as as the remaining
months of the year progress the pay
award was built into that we've just
talked about that that was rather Hefty
six uh 9% 11% 11% sorry um and one of
the other pressures that we're seeing is
homelessness so increased costs it's a
national Trend but we're seeing
increased costs um that are really
impactant on our budgets in terms of
temporary accommodation need bed and
breakfast Etc so to put that into to
context we've had an annual budget of
£18,000 for bed and breakfast that's now
150 utilities thankfully have started to
subside a little bit from the highs of
2223 so that's scooped up some of those
pressures for
us so in terms of the 2425 budget we've
got a
302,000 shortfall before any decisions
that you will take today with regards to
council tax if you were to follow the
recommendation in the report which is
for
2.99% uh that would reduce that
shortfall to 100,000 if you then take
the 92,000 off that we're expecting to
come from government for the additional
funding guarantee we're round about
£8,000 short for
2425 we have cash limited the budgets
wherever possible and all the cost
pressures from prior years have been
included in the base and that's
predominantly pay but also includes
contracts um and as I said on the
previous slide we've got pay inflation
of 3% and the government grants have
just shorted the
million in terms of the forecasts for
2526 through to 2728 the main impact is
the funding reforms from April
2026 so in all of these forecasts I've
removed the government grants I've
included the impact of the business
rates reset which is a loss of income
from the growth on business rates and
have included the transitional
protection
forecasts so just a note on on on
council tax and the decision that you'll
be taking today um the government set
the cap for council tax that's currently
set at
3% there is an increase in dependence on
council tax income in our Council
budgets and just to give you an idea 40%
of our general fund income comes from
the council tax the key thing here
though is any decision that you take
today affects every year there on in
we're increasing the base so just like a
pay increase increases the base in terms
of costs a council tax increase
increases the base in terms of
income and that's the slide that's
actually in the report that shows the
budget position in in numeric terms and
that that kind of emphasizes the
importance that middle line emphasizes
the importance of keep growing that base
in terms of council ties because you can
see that impact that has on that bottom
box bottom right after after the four
years of the
plan so moving on to the housing revenue
account it's a ring fenced account and
it's self- financed from the
rents so the general assumptions within
the HR a largely as the general fund and
Rick Nord homes experience all similar
pressures to to us you know their their
pay costs have gone up by similar
amounts to all of ours there's
increasing pressure on the sector
through the changes in regulation and as
a council we have an ambition to build
acquire and facilitate pres provision of
more affordable homes across the
district where where resources
allow so just having a quick look at the
rents that they are the main source of
income to the H and the regulator the
social housing regulator directs the
land Lords on the maximum increase every
year so that's based on a CPI plus one
and that's calculated at the 30th of
September so for 2425 the maximum rent
increase that we can set as a council is
7.7% just like the general fund we're
legally required to have a balanced
budget each year and when we pulled the
HRA together this time we needed 5% to
break even so to just ensure that we
could meet that legal requirement we
needed to increase the rents for by
5% the the recommendation in the report
is 6% and that's largely to provide some
Financial resilience for the cost of
Regulation which is a similar decision
to which you took as a council last
year and now I'm going to hand over to
Lorraine to talk to you a little bit
about social housing
regulation good afternoon
everybody just before I talk about
social housing regulation I'm just going
to put into context where we are as um
in social housing I've keep saying this
and I say every meeting I'm at at the
moment there's never been a more
challenging time for social housing and
in my experience there's been some
challenging times this is the worst I've
ever seen it lots of things are coming
our way all at once it's like a perfect
storm but the regulation is the key
thing that is going to affect us in the
next four five years the council's
ambition to build and acquire new
affordable social housing for rent is a
really ambitious Target of 400 in the
next four years it's doable it's
absolutely doable it relies on though
our being able to meet all The
Regulators requirements of us so I'll
just take you through a little bit what
the social housing regulation act means
for social housing here in Northeast
arbu so one of the key things as a
result of this is all social housing
will be H inspected by the social
housing regulator in the next four years
that could come this year it might not
come for another four years but we have
to be ready for it it I think it's
really important to say that that
inspection isn't just going to be about
rold Holmes this is definitely going to
be about this Council and its governance
arrangements with Rick Nord Holmes and
our performance that you monitor on a
regular basis and I'm pleased to say
that the
regulation the uh yeah the government
Arrangements between ourselves are
really strong the partnership
Arrangements between the council and Ral
homes have never been stronger the
Strategic Housing Partnership meetings
that that we have regularly will
demonstrate to the regulator how well
this partnership's working so that's
really important and I think it's really
key to know that the council is going to
be inspected not just wrold homes so The
Regulators has introduced four revised
consumer standards and I'll go into
those in a little while um on a
different slide but to be it's really
important that we understand it the
purpose of those standards is to give
our tenants a voice to have more
involvement with our tenants for them to
determine what they want from their
landlord and that's very clear when you
look at the
standards the new standards for decent
homes decent homes 2 is just around the
corner we're already Consulting on that
I don't know if any of you in the room
remember decent homes back in the day
but this is a much more onerous decent
home standard it requires us to know our
housing stock it needs us to know
everything about our housing stock so
that we can have programs in place to
make sure that it's fit for purpose that
it's Health it health and safety
requirements are met you'll see there
that we M mention hhsrs that is the
housing health and safety rating system
and we have to apply that to everything
we do in housing there's also a
requirement for us to have an EPC of C
by 2030 that's quite a big ask for this
type of housing stock but we are working
on that and component life cycles and
that's very much linked to the next
point which is stock condition surveying
now we've done stock condition
surveyance right since rold homes was
set up back in the day
2007 we've always done it on a fiveyear
rolling process we now have to do it
every two years we have to know every
single property's condition within the
Housing St again that's a big ask and
it's something we're working really hard
on at the moment we have excuse me we
have a team of surveyors that are doing
this work and that work is now feeding
our Capital programs which Shane I'll
talk about in a little
while some of the issues that are coming
alongside the regulation is disrepair
and we have again back to stock
condition we need to know the condition
of our housing stock when we don't we we
are in danger of getting this repair
claim now that is a process that is very
well documented but it is causing us
lots of issues and it's all to do with
the legal process that lawyers are
chasing this helping our tenants to put
in repair
claims damp and mold you'll all be aware
of the tragic event in Rochdale which
has led to our awb's law we've been
having a session this morning because
there is a consultation out because this
is going to be law the consultation
process is underway and we are
responding to that with our comments and
our feedback what that will do is mean
that we have to respond to damper mold
issues much more quickly than we have in
the past and I'll be the first to admit
that social housing hasn't always always
dealt with damp and mold in the way it
should have however there has to be a
balance because this cannot just be
about social housing landlord this has
to be about the tenants responsibility
for their property too so there is a
balance there but we have to get that
right it's incredibly important we
wouldn't want to see any further tragedy
like we saw in
Rochdale other changes coming out of the
regulation is electrical legislation is
changing and that will be a much more
speedier time scale for us to do
electrical remedial works and again I
don't know if you're aware but we do an
electrical testing program we test um
again this is on a rolling program and
this has to be brought forward because
we need to do it quicker and it is going
to become a statutory requirement it
isn't at the moment gas is but
electrical isn't gas uh safety is
Paramount to us and we are 100%
compliant with the statutary
requirements for
gas tenant satisfaction measures have
been introduced and we have been working
with them as a trial for the last year
and a half so we're very well used to
take um undertaking tenant surveys
you'll be pleased to know that we sent
out our annual tenants survey last week
it's been out there for nine days we've
already had 940 I checked before I came
940 responses and the satisfaction level
is 87 9% we are so pleased with that I
can't tell you because the average in
the industry is around 65% so we're way
above
average the regulator is also going to
publish League tables so that's going to
be a case of reporting our performance
against others that always comes with a
problem because you never know whether
you're comparing apples and oranges or
apples and pears but we do need to do
that and we are going to have to do that
is part of the
regulation all of these things that I'm
talking about come at a cost they can't
be done easily we need additional staff
for things like damp and molds Tove in
cleans of molds Etc electrical
legislation bring it quicker we need to
do more testing it all comes with a
price um the biggest one though is that
all of your senior executive and senior
housing staff have to be qualified in
cih chartered Institute of housing over
the next five years that is huge that's
absolutely huge it's usual to have a
balanced team and and have one or two
that are um in a part of cih this
requires us to have every single housing
executive qualified as a chartered
Institute of housing
member that also comes at quite a
cost alongside the regulator we now have
a housing Ombudsman who've got more
power they've got more power to publish
best practice guidance and we're seeing
more of that we've had two ommen inquir
iies this last four months and in the
past we've had none so we are seeing an
increase in housing husman
inquiries which is a good thing I have
to say it does mean we have to really
understand what we're doing for our
tenants and that we are using best
practice just to put into context though
um housing husman complaints and our
complaints rold Holmes does 880,000
contacts with our customers in a year
through the contact center we undertake
32,000 responsive repairs a year on
average and we have 49 formal complaints
last year so put that into context I
think we're doing okay however that we
can't become complacent we have to be
able to meet all of this regulation in
order for us to do what this Council
wants us to do and build new
properties just mention adaptations the
changes make have have come about as a
result of a recent high court judgment
so we have an adaptations policy which
ensures we do our adaptations but we do
them in the properties that most suit
people's needs that's had to change so
we are looking at a change to this and
possibly being able to access disabled
facilities Grant which at the moment is
not available to social housing but Jane
and I are going to have a discussion
about that see if we can make that
change otherwise we are going to have
some issues coming out of that policy
and we're going to have to make some
changes to
that so the consumer standards as I said
they're all very much focused on what's
right for the tenant what the tenant
wants from us as a landlord and what we
are doing to keep our tenants safe safe
and healthy so the safety and quality
standard it does what it says on the tin
we have to ensure that all our homes are
good quality and that they're safe for
our tenants the transparency influence
and accountability standard should
always always have been in place and
it's absolutely what we should be doing
and it's always been a key part of our
business plan so that's not new for us
the neighborhood and Community standard
relies requires landlords to engage with
other parties so that our tenants can
live in safe and well maintained
neighborhoods and feel safe in their
homes and that really does mean we have
to engage with other agencies social
Care Mental Health teams the police we
have lots of joint meetings with those
agencies to make sure that our tenants
have those safe and well-maintained
neighborhoods the tency standard sets
out the requirements for fair
allocations and lettings which we
absolutely do and it is your allocations
policy that we adere to and we we uh use
and how those tencies are managed and
ended by the landlord so again we need
to be really careful that we're doing
all the right things for our
tenants so I think in summary we have to
get the regulation right we have to be
able to demonstrate it we have have to
be able to evidence it and that's going
to be absolutely key to enable us to do
the really nice stuff which is the new
build and the Acquisitions and the
BuyBacks
Etc
stay
over there you go so just very very
briefly just to run through the general
fund projects so you'll all be aware of
the work that's going on at Clay Cross
active to replace the Charlotte Park
Leisure Center and the Clay Cross Town
Center we've also got a vehicle
replacement scheme in place and we've
also got the UK Shar Prosperity scheme
that's ongoing at the moment in terms of
the HRA we're going to be investing
another 46 million pound into Capital
Works in our existing housing stock and
we've got A10 million pound program over
the next four years to acquire
additional units as well um Lorraine's
going to now talk you through some of
the schemes that Rick no are working for
with on our
behalf I think most of you are aware of
these schemes that are currently ongoing
Whit Le Nigel referred to earlier we are
due to have 70 new homes on that estate
and our first completion is due this
year in May so we should be handing Keys
over early this year Stone broom
Bungalows will um give us 77 for rent
all of them being for rent the one thing
that we haven't made clear in here and I
I will mention is we have an application
into homes England for wrel homes to
become a developer partner and that will
allow us to access Grant which will mean
that we can do more mixed tenure schemes
we can do um a mix of HR along with RP
give us more financing opportunities and
it'll give us uh quite some considerable
Grant should that application be
accepted and we have had some really
positive feedback from homes England so
that's really good the other things
we're working on social housing
decarbonization fund you'll all be aware
of it it's the external wall insulation
work that we've been doing but alongside
that that we've been putting in extra
measures so we're putting in roofs we're
doing windows and doors lots of things
that give it a whole house approach and
we've also received uh Devolution
funding and we've been doing seven whole
house retrofits um that was a small
pocket of money but it's there and it's
something that's made it really possible
for us to do some additionality so seven
whole housee retrofit properties due
June this year we've got other schemes
in the pipeline not that I intend to go
into today but there are certainly
things that we're in discussion with
some of you about and we will be looking
to meet that Target of 400 hot homes in
the next four
years thank
you thank thanks Lorraine last slide
you'll all be pleased to know so th this
is the one that keeps me up at night so
section 25 of the Local Government Act
2003 requires that local Authority when
you're considering your budget and
setting your council tax has to report
on the adequacy of the financial
reserves in relation to budget setting
I'm I'm pleased to be able to report
that today I'm satisfied that the levels
of reserves that the council has at this
time are adequate to fund the budget
they're adequate to fund the planned
expenditure they're adequate to fund the
capital program and any potential risks
and issues that would identify I've
listed all of the reserves that we have
generally available un ring fenced there
but they are all detailed in the report
if you do want to go through them in
some more detail and I believe chair
that's where we end thank you thank you
Mrs ethic and thank you Mrs sh so that
provides a context for the uh paper that
we're considering this afternoon so uh
I'm going to hand over now to council
Kerry to uh speak and then move the
recommendations in the general fund
section which are to do with um
recommendations one to8 counc
kry thank you chair today I'm presenting
the medium-term financial plan for the
current current Year's budget along with
the original budget for
2425 and the planning budgets for the
following 3 years 27 to
28 I will first be uh presenting the
general fund budget for members
consideration and
approval there are no major changes to
the current budget we are still on track
to identify the remaining Savings of
331,000 progress will be reported to the
cabinet and scrutiny in the quarter 3
monitoring next
month the draft Financial settlement was
released on the 18th of December table
one in appendix one shows the Grants
awarded and we're now expecting a small
small windfall following the
announcement last week let me reiterate
that this is a one-off funding and there
is no commitment that this will continue
into future years when the actual
amounts are confirmed in the final State
uh
settlement that will be laid before
parliament in February we will adjust
the budget
accordingly the funding reforms have
once again been delayed and will now not
be considered until after the general
election it is widely expected that
there will be no changes in the 2526
funding meth uh methods because of this
table two in appendix one shows the
forecast position for the next four
years
2425 the gap before council tax increase
is 300 uh
302,000 this reduces to 100,000 should
the recommended Council ta council tax
increase be approved today and will
reduce to 8,000 if the government's
additional funding is in line with our
estimates the resilience Reserve will be
utilized to fund this small shortfall
and I am confident that this saving will
be comfortably achieved during the
year a council tax increase of 2.99 is
recommended for
2425 it's never easy making decisions
about the increase and a balance must be
sought between our financial position
and the impact to our
residents table two demonstrates how
important council tax income is and it
is also important to note that the
annual increase not only Services the
current Year's budget but also increases
the base for the future
years the main points to note in the
general uh fund account program are that
most of the Town deal projects will be
completed in
2425 after which the general fund
Capital program reduces
considerably finally the1 officer has
provided a view on the adequacy of the
reserves in the medium-term financial
plan and raised no
concerns our resil our resilience
Reserve will continue to provide
protection against budget gaps and the
investor save Reserve remains at a
healthy level and the general fund
balance remains in taxed
typ we recognize that we are in better
financial position than many local
authorities some of whom are struggling
to set balanced budgets next year but
nonetheless we do appreciate that there
is still a need to continue to tackle
the underlying budget
deficit in a planned and managed manner
this Council has an excellent track
record of both identifying and
delivering service efficiencies has
required alongside a strong commitment
to the financial resilience and the good
Financial
governance I'll hand back to the chair
for questions and comments are you
moving the recommendations I will move
the
recommendations I move the
recommendations in one and two then
recommendations 3 to7 in respect of the
general fund thank you I'll second that
thank
you just we had AER
circulated I'm just saying that we've
had uh an updated paper circulated which
had one to8 Council carry so I'm just
wondering are you moving one to eight
yes CH thank
you right any uh comments or questions
Council
Dale thank you chair it's no surprise to
me that Council Barker wants to detract
from the matter before us today by
focusing on darash County Council but I
think the reality from my perspective
my perspective as evidenced by the
budget that's before us today is that
actually you've inherited a very healthy
budget from the last Administration I
think councelor Kerry even said it for
himself that we have an excellent record
of achieving efficiencies um and I think
you need to look no further than the
reserves position you have a 2.6 million
pounds in the resilience Reserve which
we specifically established to help
softland the council through the
challenging times that we all knew were
to come uh postco as we're seeing now
that's in addition to 2 million in the
general fund reserve and almost 2
million in the investor save reserve the
budget that we inherited in 2019 had
only4 Million worth of reserves and I
think that's than thanks to The Prudent
management of the budget that we're in a
better position now to take on those
challenges that we're facing and it's
almost a year to the day uh since we set
the budget the current budget at the
time kener Kenyan uh was very clear that
we had allocated a worst case scenario
amount from the resilience reserve and
we would continue to deliver efficiency
IES over the course of the year to make
that allocation unnecessary and that's
exactly what's happened if you look at
what's happened to the current Year's
budget we've gone from allocating uh a
total of 784 th000 we're only actually
projected to need
331,000 and in conversation with Jane
the other day it sounds like that will
decrease even further throughout the
course of this year so the reality is
you know you inherit a very good very
good budget uh there was a a significant
use of reserves but no one was ever
intending for that to be that full
amount we were always going to deliver
efficiencies as you're seeking to do
with this year's budget the coming
Year's budget and future years as I say
you inherited a very a very uh plentiful
reserves a good strong healthy budget
and what else would a resilient Reserve
be for if it wasn't for soft Landing
some of the the impact of some of the
challenges that we're facing uh and
enabling our residents to not see uh
huge cuts to services or uh you know all
some of the you our staff to be to have
significant redundancies it's about
delivering a k a measured approach to
getting us to the next stage but what I
find I think most frustrating is the
rank hypocrisy of Labor's approach they
did their level best to trash our uh
budget last year even in May upon
becoming leader Nigel again criticized
the use of council tax uh uh to the
maximum amount and the use of reserves
in the current Year's budget they
campaigned on it vigorously during the
election uh but I'm really struggling to
find any difference in approach here
from Labor uh as councelor ker said
himself there are no major changes in
this budget and actually it's pretty
much identical uh to the Future years
projection that we adopted uh last year
it there is literally no change and I'm
struggling really to understand how
labor have had a year in office now uh
to get to grips with this budget and
there are no bright ideas for any
massive efficiencies that they promis to
reduce that need to rely on reserves or
reduce the council tax burden uh there's
just absolutely nowhere because I don't
think fundamentally you have any bright
ideas and I think unfort it's starting
to Dawn on the labor group that with
power comes responsibility and setting a
budget is never an easy task but a word
of advice from from me if you're going
to slam your opposition's approach it's
probably sensible to at least try to do
something different when you come into
power and finally I do think the
government's announcement last week of
additional funding somewhat changes
things for the council given we are in a
much healthier position uh and all
that's said before I think it's right to
show residents that we are on their side
at this difficult time uh the additional
money from government means that we
could quite comfortably drop council tax
by a further 1% uh and clearly that's
clearly obviously this has an impact on
future Year's budgets I fully understand
and accept uh the arguments around that
going into the base and and future years
uh not being quite as good but we do
have to put council tax 1% of council
tax into the uh into context it's worth
about 70,000 pounds to the council it's
not a huge amount in comparison to the
uh the efficiencies that we have a a
very strong R track record of making as
as Council Kerry has claimed you're
running out of time Council D okay thank
you clearly this is an impact on future
Year's budgets I say um I don't think
anyone thinks that the projections in
the budget are are going to be as bad as
they are because any government whatever
color is not going to drop off support
in the way that has been proposed and
obviously Jane has to do that as a as an
accountant to demonstrate worst case
scenario but no that's never really
going to happen in inflation continuing
to fall we are in a good position so I'd
like to therefore propose an amendment
to reduce cancel tax
uh request to
1.99%
ch right so that's been proposed it's
1.99% do we have a second for that
Council cupit are you wishing to speak
now so we're going to now debate the
1.99% uh part of it that's been
amended so any comments about the
1.99% amendment
Council
B yeah thank you J obviously we we've
arrived at this position with that
recommendation we've looked at all as uh
as budgets and as forecasts I think at
this stage if you're going to
propose uh that which you have the the
1% it's got to be costed somewhere Alex
it's got to be it's got to be done in in
a in a proper costed way and the effects
of that obviously we we're not going for
that we
we we' we've proposed and seconded of
2.99% uh I accept what you're saying it
the budget was in a strong State and
thank you for that uh it's uh and I
think the management of that through
through Jane and a staff has been really
really good uh I fully get that and uh
but that little bit of a carrot that
they choked out last week don't really
make a lot of difference to District
councils it's mostly for the uh social
services councils that have got all that
on uh which is desperately needed I
fully get that but we're uh we're
definitely committed to it's always a
challenge as you've said setting a
budget is not easy because people have
to pay for it and there will be a knock
on to this I don't i' D to think how
much other authorities the county uh and
the police and the uh the fire uping
their budget so it is a cumulative thing
but we as a district council need that
2.9% this year uh so because it rolls on
for future Years it'll have an impact
for next for well forever basically so
we need that
2.99% thank you councel
Hancock excuse me thank you chair I sit
here obviously as a council taxpayer and
agree with every word that Council
Dale's just said but I think sitting
here and looking at this realistically
uh and an additional 1% um cour just is
not going to make the figures work we
have got a good track record of finding
savings the problem is ultimately you're
going to get to the point where there
are no more savings to find until you
are scrapping services and making
redundancies um yes that extra 92,000
that we've had from the government it's
nice but we also know that suddenly
things come along and all of a sudden
we've got a huge bill that we weren't
expecting anyway so I think in principle
I would like to support it but
pragmatically I just don't think we can
support the
amendment thank you Council Giller CH I
must admit I came here today not
expecting to say anything because I
didn't think the tour group would say
much about Council budgets given the
debate that I think it's going to take
place in two or three weeks time but
unless things have changed dramatically
was looking at I think a 73 pound a year
increase in bandid property on top of
the 13 pound a year increase in bandid
property that the police and crime
commissioner asked for last year now any
body who knows anything about local
government Finance knows that a lot of
the restraints on the council like this
or indeed on any council is the
government uh finance and the grant we
we get and therefore the opportunity to
change things some sometimes takes time
and the difference between a 2.99% and a
1.99% 1% difference I think works out at
4 p a week to the council taxpayer
that's what we're arguing about today
which to any individual if you're really
really struggling 4p is a big difference
if you've got no money You' got no money
uh but for for a lot of people I don't I
think they'll say you know it doesn't
make a difference to them uh whether it
can make a difference to to this Council
so so I don't understand the logic of
the argument that's been put forward if
we're making a substantial change to the
council tax yes I could get that but to
proposal change that amounts to2 pound a
year if I understand the figures right
which is about 4 p a week it it doesn't
seem a big saving and uh but equally can
have an an important influence on this
Council because we all know that if you
regularly don't put the council tax up
and the government doesn't put the grant
up as well that is the road to ruin for
local authorities in the
future thank you councelor gillet
councelor adlington Stringer please
thank you chair um I admire councilor
Dale's um Praise of the conservative
Administration for protecting this
Council through a age of government
austerity economic chaos which has come
from the top down so well done for I'm
pleased we had a resilience fund to
protect ourselves from you
um
congrats putting text up is never is
never favorable it's the public are
never going to like it but unfortunately
we have to do this and looking at this
budget I must say I agree with councelor
gillet's comments I didn't think that
you would have much of a problem with
this it seems quite modest in in in much
of a way so just as your government is
trying to hold on now you're using this
populist idea a to try and cut by 1% the
tax Rises just for for a headline
approach and that really just sums up
the attitude that you're taking at the
moment and I find that quite appalling
so I will be supporting the labor
group's budget today um
and
join no um so yeah fantastic thank you
very much thank you and Council Shipman
thank you chair um I agree with my
colleague C and actually um
the what's been said by other people so
far but the problem I have and I've been
saying this for a good couple of years
now is that we're being told to look at
a budget and vote on it and there's no
cost-saving measures that are actually
put forward for councilors to review now
I don't think that's giving counselors
you know all the information to make an
informed decision on what ultimately is
we're asking residents to pay more or
less is the conservative amendment is
and actually if you look at these
figures it's very difficult not to
vote for The increased council tax but
it's also difficult to vote um for it
and against it and it's it's I would
like proposals com forward we've been
we're nearly 12 months on now since the
labor Administration has took over and
we've still not had this detailed plan
that that I think we're all promised
last year about what's going to be done
and how money is going to be saved and
where is it coming from and where are
the savings we are G you know we're
asking to approve the budget here
it's still got P Pie in the Sky
estimations on what charlot Park's going
to do I rais that this in Services
scrutiny and I still had no additional
information in terms of what what the
business analysis behind it was what the
business case was I'd like to see that
just to find out what their kind of
logic on it all was you'll see killer
Marsh leure Center which again I've been
banging on about for years this was the
amount we were going to spend on kiler
Mar was supposed to reduce year on year
since we took it off it's now flying up
to the tune of from this year over
125,000 we were not promised that when
we were giving the business case on
killer Marsh so why on Earth should we
trust the business case of charlot park
when that has kind of gone to be a mess
to be fairing Kil Mar because what we
was promised and told and asked to vote
on again was completely
wrong well so so yeah I won't be voting
for the amendment purely because I'm not
I don't feel informed enough to be able
to vote a reduction in council tax from
what's been proposed um but I can't
support the budget either so I'm in a
difficult position as as a counselor on
this Council um so that's my position I
won't be voting for this amendment thank
you
chair counc
Baker thank you
chair uh being new to these budget
arrangements as a new
counselor uh I I don't feel fully
informed I'll Echo some of councelor
Shipman's comments for example dwelling
rents I did ask this in the scrutiny
committee uh appears a flat line after
this financial year and yet we bake in
council tax Rises why don't we I think
we've gone on to an HRA matter we're not
discussing that we're discussing general
fund right I apologize if that's the
case uh in other words then in my
opinion there are a few things in the
HRA matter that affect the overall
Financial pos position of the council
and it isn't as pessimistic as I believe
is made out we don't have enough
information so to say that we can't
afford to reduce council tax a little I
think is
incorrect any other
comments not I'll return to council Dale
for right of reply Council C
no she said no council Dale thank you
chair um I think agree with quite a lot
of what councelor Shipman said actually
I think the the way that we budget in
this Council does leave quite a lot of
information you know out of it County as
as is well known we have a long list of
savings proposals to to achieve a
balanced budget whereas at this Council
we I think we offset that by uh by
striking out from reserves and and and
trying to achieve efficiencies along the
way which we have a good track Rec of
doing but members don't get that
information so I think there's a fair
point around that and and I think it's
you know you know take it as
constructive criticism that that could
be uh better looked at in future in
terms of the council tax reduction I
think it's we're in a position where as
I say we've got six uh6 million pound
satin reserves uh and we're still asking
for the full council tax amount we know
that we're going to get a balanced
budget this year because the shortfall
is is as low as 100,000 that'll be wiped
out by the extra 92 so we're going to
get a balanced budget if not better
we're probably going to end up with a
surplus at the end of this year and
therefore I think it's right it's it's
right to only ask residents to to pay
what we actually need and I think I do
accept the position about the the future
years base uh and we will face difficult
times to come I'm sure but I don't think
they'll be as bad as what's projected in
the budget because it is worst case
scenario planning so I do think we can
afford that the government announcement
does change the uh change things quite
significantly and I think it's a it
might only be a few pennies as as
councelor jillet said maybe enough to
buy a teake and a bun or whatever
councel car said a few years ago uh but
you know I think that's an important
statement to our residents that we're
not asking them to pay uh to line the
council's coffers which could well very
be very well be the case at the end of
this year if we do end up with a surplus
uh situation uh so yeah that's that's my
response thank you Council Dale so what
we're going to do in a moment is we are
going to turn to vote on the amendments
so that's the recommendation number four
the amendment is that the um council tax
will be
1.99% so that's the amendment so Mr
Sternberg anything on the voting um
chair just a reminder for anybody who
needs it it's on the card to tell you
which way to vote thank you just to
remind people on the on these Finance
matters this is a recorded vote so on
the amendment this will be recorded so
what that means is that when we finish
vote in that um a copy of this will be
added to the minutes as a recorded
version of how we
voted I think that's it so we let us go
to the
vote I'm just reminding
people green for red against Amber
fromstein right just any final changes
in case anybody wants a moment
more no right show the results then
please the amendment is lost so we
return to the substantive uh
recommendations as proposed by Council
Kerry and seconded by counselor Barker
are there any other comments or
questions about the
substantive
recommendations Council weather
all yeah it was it was just a question
actually about the um H&D degree um
level qualifications that are needed
that you you mentioned and I wondered
whether I think we're back on HRA again
oh sorry so can we you can save that for
part two thank you thank
you uh councelor
Hancock thank you chair yeah um I did
actually pull my colleague up for you
when he started debating the substantive
motion but I am going to repeat largely
what he said I mean we we didn't feel
that we could support the amendment but
equally so we're being asked to uh to
vote now on the medium-term financial
plan on the general account and uh it
doesn't look which is why obviously we
didn't support the amendment we do need
to build this base as quickly as
possible some of the projections I would
say are unrealistic so once we've got um
worst case scenarios in terms of of
where we go with the reserves we've also
got I would say some very favorable
projections as as Ross touched on in
terms of income streams which I don't
think will necessarily be
achieved I I can't support the budget as
it stands because we keep going coming
back to a position where we're kicking
the can down the road and saying we need
to keep looking at this we need to look
at that we need to find more savings
sooner or later that's going to come
knocking on the door and I have absolute
respect for Jane so please don't take
this out of context but I've got no
doubt that in pretty much every counil
in the country at least a year or two
ago had the1 officer standing there
saying exactly the same thing um and uh
a lot of them are not finding themselves
in this position anymore I'm not using
it to politically Point score at all
because actually in times like this we
should all be joining forces and coming
up with something that that is workable
um so whilst yes I think we we do need
to keep that that 299 council tax I
think we we seriously need to start
looking hard and fast at where these
savings are going to come from and how
we are going to balance this budget in
the um in the medium term thank you and
Council
corwell
can you hear me yeah so I just I'd
actually like to just commend the new um
Administration who is eight months old
not a year in the the new collaborative
way of working so um two or three weeks
ago we had a joint scrutiny committee
where we all collaborated we all all the
chairs and all the vice chairs of all
the scrutiny committees had the
opportunity to discuss and scrutinize
the reports that are in front of you
today
that was the opportunity for us to
scrutinize this and nobody had any major
questions so I just want to commend the
new way of
working thank you any other
comments we return to councilor Barker
who's a second if you've got any
comments you want to make not massively
but I think what Su just said it does
have Merit we did have a meeting in here
uh it wasn't brilliantly attended but
that no issues were raised at that
meeting and that were cross party we
were all there we had an opportunity to
ask questions uh and and obviously that
were an opportunity to suggest what
you've suggested there uh but it seemed
to be a consensus listening to what Jane
had said that the 2.99% was an
acceptable uh increase so uh I'll second
the thank you I had gone to the second
I'm going to allow you to sneak in
Council Shipman before we go back to the
proposer but only because it's you thank
you very much chair it's just to clear
up a point about the the opportunities
that we've all had to scrutinize this
budget we had it at the services
scrutiny I didn't attend the meeting at
the at the The Joint Services committee
over schol because I was at work but at
the services
scrutiny I was Raising points
particularly about the income streams
and what's projected and where we're
spending our money um and at that
meeting those questions were unanswered
so
this but this is the opportunity where
we can still raise issues going forward
and and ultimately we're voting on
something we've got a debate and
councilors should you know be able to
argue their point and try and convince
the rest of the councilors to vote a
certain way um but yeah we we we do
scrutinize the budget but I'm still Ona
with it because I've not had the answers
that I've been asking
for I'll take that as a a clarification
Point Council Kerry right a reply
Dr of reply I I I'm looking at what's
been said over all the time um I do
appreciate that uh the
conservatives uh left us in a reasonable
position and I've said that for a long
time but the first four years of the
Tory uh people uh go uh
Administration said we left them in a
hole and we didn't leave them in a hole
we left them virtually in the same
position that they left us in and I've
acknowledged that the conservatives have
left us uh in a reasonable position but
I don't think the conservatives ever
acknowledge that we left them in a
reasonable position we didn't take we
didn't uh throw the baby out with the
bath water and spend it all before a
change over occurred I I'm quite happy
and I will acknowledge that on the other
stand the settlement and the council tax
uh this windfall shouldn't count for
anything it's not in our possession yet
and it is likely likely to be a very
small amount we're talking about
90,000 and if you take 1% off uh the
budget this year you will lose that 9
90,000
off your base rate that will you you
will lose year on year on year the
addition is a one-off payment if we
don't go up to the full amount we shall
lose that equivalent of aund uh roughly
100,000 per year at infin item
um it's still in times of
uncertainty
uh we certain certainly won't let
our reserves grow higher and higher
because I'm sure we can find something
very useful to do with it we might even
get uh help with buses and transport and
all sorts of things and no doubt that
the County Council will pass down uh in
in their type situation at least
£1,000 worth of things they gave to us
over the next three years that we'll be
expected to do because they can't afford
it I I'm you know let's take the vote
and get on with
it thank you Council Kerry for moving
the meeting on um so let's get to the
vote then and get on with it so uh this
just to remind you again this is a
recorded vote so uh red is against Green
for and uh amber to abstain so let's
vote please
hopefully we've all
voted
keeps changing right so can we show the
result oh apparently we are showing
results
um could you wait next time please so um
as you can see 62% fall so uh one to8 is
carried so that's the general fund we
are going to move to the HR where we've
got millions of questions we know that
will be coming up however the Ral
members will have to leave which means
as well as my s the vice chair will also
have to leave we don't have an immediate
past chair so we need to um vote for
someone from the body of the meeting
that uh is able to take the chair for
this part of the meeting so do we have
any nominations please Council bar can I
move councilor Le on please seconded
thank you do we have any other
nominations all those in favor of
council
harthorn anyone
against any
abstentions you're duly elected for the
next few minutes and Council hearts on
thank
you
vac
right right for this short session I'll
be uh taking over uh the chair's
position
um I'd like to ask councelor Kerry um as
the uh Finance person to speak um and
councilor Barker will move and second a
motion to approve the
recommendations so over to councelor
Kerry
yeah I will now move on to the housing
revenue
account the main point of note as we've
just heard is the pressure being created
by the increased demand and impact of
Regulation offices at the council and
reel homes are working closely together
to continue to provide highquality
Housing Services for our tenants that
also meet the expectations for social
housing regulator but the associated
costs of delivery are growing in
addition the costs known to us at this
time have been included in the budget
and the position will be kept under
review having taken into consideration
the budget pressures the impact on the
tenants and the rent standard which
allows a r rent increases of up to
7.7% the annual rent increase we are
recommending the council for this year
uh is
6% as well of this as well as the 57
million investment in our stock over the
next four years the HRA Capital program
also includes new build scheme at North
Wingfield and the Regeneration scheme at
Stone broom I think what I really like
to say here is
that 5% would give us an absolute break
a minimum breakthrough uh on the rents
as they
stand when you take into consideration
the new uh regulations that have been
imposed on this year that takes us over
the
5% we can go
7.7 in our opinion six would be the I
would be the uh way to go and chair I
move uh that
uh the recommendations in 8 to 13 in
respect of the H chair thank you I'll
second that thank you thank you Council
Barker clarify to 14 uh can we just
clarify that uh that's Parts 9 to 14 on
the on the report 9 to 14
sorry right thank you right do we have
any questions
Council Dale yeah thank you uh chair I
think yet again for me the rhetoric
isn't matching the reality uh from labor
last year we were heavily criticized for
proposing a 5% increase on rents which
was 2% lower than the government ceiling
uh for that not being enough uh given
the challenges that our residents were
facing here we are today we know that
inflation is significantly down I think
most residents will be expecting a lower
increase uh this year but we've got a %
increase uh and I think people can tell
the difference between what you say and
what you do and and I thought for the
sake of
consistency uh the labor group would
have gone lower uh lower than us or at
least to that 5% Break Even point to
demonstrate that they really are on the
side of the people that they claimed to
be on the side of only last year um I
think it's fair to say our group has got
pretty mixed views on this recognizing
the challenge for Council tenants giving
the ongoing pressures on household
budgets obviously we recognize the need
to invest in housing stock and and you
know it was our Administration that
secured the social housing
decarbonization scheme and and made huge
strides forwards in terms of the the
insulation schemes and we think that
that's really important to continue
doing and that costs money you know we
know that construction inflation is is
very significant um so I think from our
perspective we'll be abstaining uh and
it's for the labor Administration you've
made your bed it's for you to lie in it
um and I think that's the right approach
but as I say it's uh it's interesting
that the consisten doesn't really follow
from last year and what we experienced
in the chamber last
year thank you Council Dale anybody else
want to
contribute thank you
CH sorry is you've not come up on the
screen you're supposed to best the uh
yes I'll I'll bring you in first yeah
councelor bker Baker sorry not bker
sorry thank you chair well I'll I
reiterate the question I made earlier
which I did make at the scrutiny joint
scrutiny committee that after the year
2425 the rental income flat lines and I
still despite the explanation was given
didn't quite understand why why the
proposed rent increase isn't baked into
that and uh the other thing is that
depreciation is shown at 8.3 million but
that is just a book figure isn't it
that's not an actual outgoing unless
we're planning to renew the housing
stock could could I have some
Enlightenment as to whether we are
planning to renew the housing stock and
if so at what period and at what rate
are we planning to do that and why why
the rent flat lines at 3 5,600,000 or
thereabouts for the next four
years
please uh Jane if You' like to come in
on that please certainly would chair yes
thank thank you very much so as we
discussed councelor Baker at the at the
um scrutiny committee the rents only
include the rent increase that's
proposed today so they only include the
6% that's included today we don't build
rent increases in going forward just
like we don't do council tax increases
because that is your decision in the
chamber year on year on year so it would
it's it's not appropriate for me to
assume rent increases year on year that
is your decision so that's why we don't
including rent increases the reason that
it flat lines is the voids so the voids
go up and down up and down up and down
so we tend to focus in a prudent aspect
as counsil uh Dale quite rightly pointed
out I am prudent um I do have to make
sure that that we can you know meet the
expectations required um and so the
voids tend to change the F figure year
on year on year but they are they are
fairly static we also have to build in
right to buys and you'll be aware that
we lose around about 60 properties a
year through right to buy so that's the
answer to the first part of the question
how long have you got to talk about
depreciation so you're absolutely right
depreciation is a book entry but we
actually use it to fund the major
repairs so the major repairs Reserve
which funds the capital program is made
up of um an element of depreciation and
a contribution from the capital reserve
as well so so it is actually used to
fund the capital program that's how
depreciation works it's a set aside to
fund the investment in the
assets hope hope that helps
uh thank you Jan um counselor
Shipman thank you chair um I do think
it's quite ironic actually that um it
appears that the labor group and the
conservative group are pretty much two
sides of the same coin because when
you're in opposition you'll argue one
point and then when you take control of
the council you basically just become
each other and make rents in increases
council tax increases provide us with no
substance to the figures really um it's
just high level figures and high level
explanations we've got no meat on the
bone um I won't be supporting U the um
part of this budget I have concerns
about um where the money is going um
I've met with um the rain about the
relationship um that the council has
with Rick neld and I think that that
needs constant review just to make sure
it is the best vehicle for the council
to be providing its homes um and I stand
by that um um and I can't support what
we've got in front of us today um so
I'll be voting against this thank you
chair Council weather
all Yes um it was a question really
about the um the comment that was made
about the uh high level qualifications
level four qualifications that are
required for staff executive um housing
staff um h& H&D stroke degree and I
wondered if there had been any
investigations around using your
apprenticeship Levy to actually fund
that um through the apprenticeship
program it is possible to get those
level four qualifications and use your
Levy uh which is a substantial could be
a substantial
saving um I'm I'm gonna ask Lorraine to
answer that question
please yes the actual qualification is
chared an Institute of housing as well
as um housing degree but it's at level
seven so it is a higher level and that's
that's the difference we do use the
apprenticeship Levy but not for that
particular part of
it right thank you uh right uh Council
car do you want to uh make a
reply
only unless we're going to the vote
chair sorry we will be going to the
chair to the vote after he's right to
reply yeah we will be going to the uh
vote after you right to reply that's
well yes the National Rent Gardens is in
place this year here at CPI plus 1% so
that becomes 7.7 the maximum that could
be charged as with the council tax
setting the impact on tenants has to be
balanced with the need to generate
additional revenues as the HRA is
completely self- financed annual rent
increases are fundamental to ensuring
that our homes continue to be
well-maintained and managed a recent
poll shows large proportion of the
council's HR nationally are following
the guidance up to the maximum we have
all o only just recovered from the four
years of rent cuts and as the report
details the cost of increased demand and
regulation is create creating budget
pressures and that is for the reason
that we go from five to
6% uh
7.7 less six is
1.7 uh the conserv told us that they had
what was it five and uh you you took it
to
three seven and five seven and five uh
well with 0 not three of a percent is
all we're arguing about we're we're
nearly on the same page thank you I
don't want to say anything else
chair thank you councel car it right um
the vote will be take taken
electronically using the new system I
would like the monitoring officer to now
conduct this once again it will be a
recorded
vote
um and you vote in that one got somebody
else's name
on Martin ther just voted in favor on
[Laughter]
it make sure that's corrected that will
be reflected in
the
well just say they AR sure at the top
here have I got two PS of
[Laughter]
it can I have that
regular right I presume everyone's voted
and are happy with the vote
um the motion has been
approved yeah so we've got 63% in favor
5% against and
13 uh 32% abstain abstain right I think
we can now on back to council aak can we
to if I might chair just to make clear
the chair will only have one vote in the
recorded vote in the meeting so that
will be one fewer
right I will take my seat
again yes I I quite agree we were
looking Chang it's
changed
yeah but we now
got we look at
it
right
just to confirm
members just to be clear members I've
just had to confirm councelor Thacker
does not appear in the um broadcasters
having
voted
well thank you everyone and thank you
councelor Hartson for chairing the
meeting good help lots of HRA
questions so we now move to item eight
the treasury strategy
reports
so back to oh Council
Kerry the purpose of this report is to
provide council with the necessary
information to approve the suite of
Treasury strategies for the period 22 uh
2324 to
2728 the strategies are compliant with
both sit for code of Treasury management
and the
mhg's investment Guidance the suite
comprises of four
strategies the treasury management
strategy strategy which provides the
framework for managing the council's
cash flows borrowing and Investments for
the period the capital strategy which is
intended to provide the high level of
consise overview of how capital
expenditure Capital financing and
treasury management activity contributes
to the provision of the council
Services the investment strategy which
focuses on investments made for service
purposes
and Commercial region rather than those
made for treasury
management and the flexible Capital
receipt strategy which defines the
specific use of receipts as per section
15 brackets 1 a of the Local Government
Act
2023 this is a piece of paper uh that we
have to approve yearly it is nothing to
do
with
our uh figures of the running of the
council it is the guidelines that all
the figures that we do produce at
different times and methods of payments
and receipts and cash transfers and
banking Etc and the balances is actual
in in place it's just the guidelines for
the whole uh of the and of of the
treasury management and we are uh
obliged once a year to bring it to the
council for recommendations that we are
actually keeping within that guidance
chair I move
recommendations in Chan in
recommendations one to four on the
treasury management
strategy I'll second that thank
you any comments or
questions
um I I don't think Council ker need a
right of reply no thank you so we'll
move to the vote so uh you know how to
vote by
now
give me anyone a second to change their
mind right could show the results
please surprisingly carried thank you so
item nine appointments to
committees so I'm going to hand over to
uh Mr Sternberg please thank you chair
this report is to recommend a change to
the membership of the planning committee
for the majority group it is recommended
that Council G replaces Council foret on
planning committee and the
recommendation is before you thank you
chair do we have a mover for the
recommendation that thank you do we have
a second
there thank you Council Barry any
comments or
questions I think we'll do this one on
show of hands all those in
favor anyone
against any abstentions
thank you that's
carried so move to item 10 which is
answering any questions from Members
asked under procedure rule number
9.2 so question a is from councilor Lacy
oh you please Council Laing thank you
chair like other communities in
Northeast darbishire many residents of
kiler Mar rely on the public transport
Network to see family and friends go to
work go shopping and for their leisure
activities yet bus services in our
village are unreliable and continue to
deteriorate leaving many people stranded
whilst responsibility for local bus
services do not rest with this Council
residents look to us to Champion their
cause would the leader of the council
agree to raise these concerns of killer
Marsh residents with both darbishire
County Council and the local bus
companies Council Barett
reply thank you yeah uh thanks for your
question yeah I'm sure the simple answer
to this is yes uh and cuz I know it's a
big issue for the local bus services
have been not just in killer Marsh uh
but all around the district district
including oore side Morton hwood pilsley
and even Clay Cross and North Wingfield
my Village uh which by car comparison
got better services but uh they are
becoming more unreliable uh I was
waiting 34 an hour all the day for a b
lipping things but rightly recognize
this Council does not have a
responsibility for public transport but
that doesn't mean that we can't act as a
local voice of a community so I'll give
you a commitment that after today I will
raise your concern with the County
Council and ask what they are doing and
are proposing to do address this issue
after talking to the County Council I
will also be more willing to speak to
the local bus companies if needs be and
I'll report back to you Council Lacy
with the outcome of these conversations
so that you can report back to your
constituents on why they are having
these problems and what this and other
agencies are doing to resolve them you
supplementary question Council Lacy can
I be cheeky and ask if you can um
arrange for there to be a a bus link to
the tram stop halfway as people do
depend a lot on the tram to get to other
areas in Sheffield Council baret a reply
to The Cheeky question oh yeah no that
was fair enough I think that's a fair
fair question it's some that uh I think
people have mentioned to me in past not
just from kilam Mar but from eckington
about trying to have a connect better
connectivity between Kil Mar eckington
and that Tramway halfway because uh it's
not far but it's far enough if you've
got to walk it so uh I shall definitely
uh bring that up as well as with the
conversations are thank you thank you
and question B then councelor Dale to
councel
Pickering thank you chair uh does the
cabinet member believe that decisions
made by the planning committee should be
consistent with local and National
planning policies Council Pickering to
reply thank you uh for your question
councel Dale um do I believe that
decisions made by the planning committee
should be consistent with planning
National policy yes
um but for Council Dale's information of
course planning law does set out that
decisions on uh planning applications
must be determined in in accordance with
the development plan thank you
supplementary question Council
Dale thank you Council Pickering for the
response in order to ensure those
decisions are compliant with the policy
and in the interest of the reputation of
the council does the cabinet member also
believe it's important for all members
of the committee to engage meaningfully
during the discuss discussion and the
debate on applications offering Fair
scrutiny and challenge uh to officers
and articulating why they've arrived at
certain conclusions and if so can he
confirm if he's spoken to the labor
members of the committee who've been the
subject of complaints for failing to do
that and essentially remaining entirely
silent during meetings two questions in
one Council Pickering to reply uh there
are two questions chair thank you um
I've not personally received any
complaints um and it's not for me to
instruct me members on how they conduct
themselves in committees it's how they
feel comfortable with that and what
questions they might want to
ask thank
you question C then Council
cupit thank you chair uh so it's
question to council Barker um given its
potential impact on communities in this
District could the leader of the council
explain why Northeast arish District
Council have offered no objections or
concerns to the current planning
application Ava 2023
0764 for 185 new homes which is
currently being considered by am Valley
burough Council Council Barker to
reply yeah thank you to be honest
Charlotte I'm a bit surprised with this
this question uh and I'm sure you're
aware that really it's not good practice
for other councils to get involved with
neighboring authorities planning things
because unless there's a really strong
case that it it's going to that
development would affect our local
plan uh however whilst not objecting to
the development it would work out that
uh that we we did submit some comments
and I've got them I've got them written
down here so because we ask that the
Heritage assessment should include an
assessment of the development on the
settings of the Des designated Heritage
asset within Northeast arer including
particular sh and Lodge Farmhouse the
cluster of listed buildings within Amber
Mill and too Conservation Area we also
commented that conditions should be
included that appropriate design and
Landscaping be included to minimize the
visual impact of the development upon
Countryside and to maintain a visual
separation between the built settlement
of alfen and Sheron parish and I'm also
aware that officers did comment in
relation to potential H housing sites in
this general area when Amber Valley were
doing their local plan consultation so
given that I'm not sure what you're
really alluding to suppl requesting
Council
cupit thanks chair and and thank you
Council Barker for your reply I I think
it's exactly that that you've just
mentioned that it seems there's a bit of
a gap between the comments and the sort
of OB objections and concerns that the
council submitted when the site was
considered for the core strategy or or
their draft local plan and then at this
stage when it is a full application orbe
it a speculative one because I know I'm
valy haven't got a local plan that we
haven't raised those same concerns other
than the heritage aspect what the
question particularly given so it's just
to ask how do you reconcile the two and
why we haven't continued uh raising
those exact concerns that we ra raised
previously chair thank you Council B has
a reply to that I I'll just read this
bit I don't know if it answers your
question but it's off it's off the thing
that we submitted but it says in
conclusion of conditions on any approval
that any reserve matter proposal include
appropriate design and Landscaping to M
minimize the visual impact of the
development upon Countryside to the
north and to maintain their visual
separation between the built settlement
so to me that's that's saying that when
they come back Reserve matters we've
already put that into the system so and
I did look on site there were 32 pages
of objections to this uh to this thing
uh so uh I think they've got enough
objections without without us
particularly getting
involved question D then councelor
adlington
Stringer thank you chair uh question to
councelor Pickering um this Council
promised to be a cleaner uh Council and
to review the road sweeping regime uh
residents in wingerworth have had
particular issues uh given the recent
flooding uh but even without uh
excessive water uh drains across our
Village um are routinely blocked um and
so I'm wondering when this plan will
come into place what it will look like
and how you plan to alleviate the
concerns of so many of my residents
thank you coun Pickering to
reply thank you um Council adlington
Stringer for that um uh two parts in
that really the neglected and blocked
drains are the responsibility of
darbishire County Council um and uh we
do some work on behalf of them they
contract that out to us and due to
recent events that you just alluded to
the County Council of re distributed
elements of the gullying emptying
schedule um to ensure that problem
drains are serviced more regularly um
for us with the street cleansing yes a
review um will take place it's been in
the scope of a lot of bigger Works we've
got the new Depo that's uh that's been
mentioned um but more specifically the
street cleansing is a more detailed
piece of work uh and that's due to
commence in April this year um in just a
couple of three months um
recommendations for any service change
will be presented uh following that
review thank you do you have a
supplementary question Council Addington
Stringer thank you um will you be
willing to engage with the County
Council to cover this shortfall this Gap
and particularly given their well
tremendous mismanagement of their budget
how will we
as two separate authorities make sure
that residents are getting value for
money they're getting the services that
we promis them between between councils
making sure that no gaps are left thank
you Pickering to reply thank you chair
as far as the street cleansing is
concerned I said the review will take
place will present any changes uh in the
meantime um if customers are concerned
about debris residents are concerned
about Dey they can contact Street Scene
um who will try to clear them as a
priority um of course we'll talk to
darbishire County Council um it's their
funding pot we're dependent on at the
end of the day um and we know what kind
of a mess they're in there whether they
set their council tax rates higher or
lower um it'll be entirely up to them
but we're dependent on that contract
from darbishire County
Council thank you so move to item 11 to
consider any motions from Members under
procedure rule number
10 so motion a is proposed by councelor
wetheral over to you
please
thank you chair and um if uh if Council
will bear with me I have a a side of A4
actually to read out um uh regarding
safety measures on the
a632 um the a632 bcts ashover ward
between spite winter and the top of
slack Hill and is a well-known and
renowned trouble spot for traffic
collisions and accidents I'm sure you're
all aware of the road from August 23 to
December 23 there were four deaths on
this road and three of these occurred in
the two weeks before Christmas in
addition to the fatalities there are
countless collisions every week some of
which are reported to the police and
some not this is a dangerous road and is
well known to be a dangerous road the
leader of darbishire County Council in a
recent parish council meeting described
it as probably the most dangerous road
in darbishire
our MP darbishire County Council myself
as District counselor and the local
Parish Council are in regular contact
with each other and every time there is
another death or serious incident an
investigation takes place that confirms
that a variety of aspects of that road
make it very dangerous one aspect that
all agree is a factor is the speed that
some motorists achieve on What's called
the flying Mile and slack Hill
particularly the run up to the hill as a
result 50 m per hour speed limits have
been imposed along most of the stretch
of this road with 40 m hour limits
through keled which is approximately a
quarter of a mile stretch although these
although these speed limits have been
imposed that there are no enforcement
measures in place and darbishire County
Council data from April last year shows
that this speed limit is routinely
flouted by
motorists halfway up slack Hill 52% of
motorists are going faster than the 50 m
per hour limit over a Six-Day speed data
collection period by DCC in a April last
year 5,014 vehicles were exceeding the
speed limit and 4% 385 Vehicles were
traveling above 70 M hour with 24
Vehicles traveling between 90 and 110
mil hour halfway up slack Hill this is
law breaking on an industrial scale and
is leading to increasing fatalities and
near misses that amount to distress for
the community who witnessed these the
Emergency Services who have to deal with
these incidents and anguish anguish for
the families of the deceased injured and
traumatized darisha P police have
confirmed in writing that the whole of
for for the whole of darbishire there
are merely three enforcement Vans and
one Enforcement Motorcycle and that
unfortunately because there is no safe
place for example hard standing to
locate one of these Vans or the
motorcycle on the a632 they cannot
enforce routine L the local community
also acknowledged that periodic
enforcement is not an effective
deterrent as motorists inform each other
through social media of the presence of
the Vans and Flash Flash each other
warnings to slow down to avoid detection
having said this darbishire police have
had a very visible presence over the
past few weeks and the community have
noted this and are very
grateful darbishire police have
confirmed in writing that average speed
cameras are needed on the a632 to reduce
collisions whilst the accident
investigations show that there are
complexities associated with all the
accidents all parties agree that
enforcing reduced speeds will ensure
that ex excessive speed is not a factor
in any future
collisions highways is a service
delivered by darbishire County Council
and we are fortunate to have councelor
cupit as Cabinet member for highways and
transport for darbishire County Council
also Northeast darbishire District
counselor I've noted her declaration
earlier um and uh and I understand that
position thank you I would urge us all
to make whatever commitments we can to
work closely together and with all key
stakeholders and partner agencies
locally and nationally to ensure that
average speed cameras are installed on
the a632 as quickly as possible in 2024
so that there is a consequent reduction
in road traffic collisions serious
accidents and deaths Northeast arer
council's and officers views and ideas
will be welcomed by the ashover
Community Action Group who have asked me
to be their spokesperson and to urge
anyone who might be able to help
expedite consistent enforcement through
average speed cameras on this stretch of
the
a632 all constructive ideas or help that
can be given will be gratefully received
and the sorts of things that I was
thinking of was letters of support
uh letters and personal testimonies of
anybody who's seen an accident there or
and been involved in an accident that we
can collect as we are doing now um and
present to the authorities and it's a a
complex mixture of stakeholders and
authorities that are involved but we
just want to demonstrate the strength of
feeling really and we ask this Council
to help in whatever way that they
possibly can thank you chair can I take
it Council whether or all that you're
formally moving the motion then is set
as down on page three of the
agenda yes yes I am thank you thank you
and do we have a second Council Cooper
are you reserving your right to speak
can I yes of course you can
yeah uh just to say yes I will be
seconding uh the motion whilst I
acknowledged not all accidents are down
to speed I think this Motion makes makes
perfect
sense and I will be second in and hope
that other members will or all of
members will do the same purely from a
public safety point of view thank you
thank you Council
Barker yeah thanks alen for uh for this
motion and uh I know how passionate you
are about it and have you just uh what
you've just said and uh and I know
you've been affected personally by uh by
one of the accidents
uh and I also appreciate the community
concern in the
village I'd also want to pass on my
sympathies to the families of the people
who died recently in that that accident
at Christmas and I can assure you that I
will do it whatever I can to assist you
in your campaign and to try to make this
road and some of its Junctions as safe
as possible I think we all accept that
the a632 has had more than its share of
accidents however preventing them
further ones is not easy given there's
multiple reasons why it's so dangerous
road safety is as you recognize is an
issue for the iway authority and the
police but having said that my group are
more are more than happy to support your
motion and whatever the outcome of
today's vote perhaps we could agree to
meet at a future date to determine how
you think this Council can best help you
in your campaign J thank you Council Bar
Council
Dale thank you chair um absolutely Echo
councilor Barker's comments and
understand the concern that this is a
very sensitive issue clearly any
fatalities or injuries on on any of our
roads are an absolute tragedy uh and and
a real cause for concern and our
sympathies absolutely will also go to
the to the families who've lost loved
ones I think all of us across the
chamber want to see action on on uh
improving Road Safety across darvish's
roads that's reflected in I know various
members from across the chamber will
take part in things like Community speed
watch and obviously with some some
development in terms of Sids in some
roads but as CC Barker articulated it's
not always an easy uh matter to resolve
there are often you know a huge number
of complicating factors um as councelor
WEA all said councelor Lewis as the
local county councelor is is equally as
concerned as you are and has has been I
know regularly emailing um the police
about the issues and and pushing for
Solutions locally uh in the same way I
think the scope of the motion from our
perspective very clearly falls under DCC
and the police um I think there's little
that D any DDC can do from a practical
perspective uh and while we obviously
support the the intent of the motion I
think our group would rather obstain on
the basis of that being a County Council
matter but we'll happily speak to um to
Barry and to Charlotte who obviously
can't speak now about the issue external
to this meeting to to see what we can do
to
support councilor Hancock
thank you chair um I was actually just
going to say something about that tweet
kind of at the end um this to me isn't a
political issue it isn't a partisan
issue it's a matter of conscience um yes
as people say it's it is outside of our
remit but that's not actually what
council everyone is asking for she's
asking us as a council to do what we can
um and and I think obvious condolences
which are just words um when someone
lost someone in such a horrible way
nobody can ever express it or Express
genuine regret unless they've been
through it themselves um but I would say
unquestionably um she would have my
backing and uh and I would have hoped
from from fully across the chamber
because as I say this to me is is a
personal conscience issue it's it's not
a partisan one at all thank you Council
adlington
Stringer thank you chair um just to Echo
councelor Han CO's um words there that
this isn't a party political issue um at
all and that I my thanks with Council
weatherall for bringing this to our
attention and I hope that we do give
this our full support today um it's only
right um my thoughts are with those that
have been impacted by
this this failure of of Road management
and I hope that we can find a solution
as a as a war member for wingerworth we
often encounter this this part this
patch of Road and I've often found
myself actually Once Upon a Time broken
down halfway up and having to roll back
down yes it was quite an interesting
experience so I think there more can be
done uh the road needs to be made safer
in a lot of different ways uh but this
is a is a great first step and hopefully
we see actions from the County Council
given off full support today thank you
very much thank you thank you any other
comments or
questions if not then could we move to
the vote right oh sorry yes I should
have apologies Council weather all right
of
reply okay no just just to thank Council
really for consideration of this motion
um and any support that you can give
will be gratefully received very much
sir than you thank you Council weather
all and apologies for that so we move to
the vote on motion
eight
it
last few moments to let the voting
settle we can see the results
please that's it overwhelmingly four so
the the motion is
passed thank you motion B then proposed
by councelor Dale over to
you
okay sorry thank you chair um appreciate
that the motion may appear to be uh
parochial but I just want to ensure
everyone from across the chamber this is
not uh the case at all I uh while the
application may come may have come
forward in my w it's approval for me um
has far-reaching consequences for the
whole District uh and for me it sets a
dangerous precedent as far as settlement
development limits and the green belt
are concerned uh which we know you know
covers all of the district in one way or
another uh I won't dwell on all the
finer details either hopefully the
motion summarizes fairly well what has
happened with this application uh but I
would encourage members to review the
recording of the of the meeting and
watch the debate for yourselves to see
why it matters uh but very briefly for
those who are unaware the application
hinged on local polic local plan policy
lc3 which sets five really important
tests which all need to be met in order
to permit limited affordable housing uh
to meet local community needs outside of
settlement develop limits including
within the green belt uh in the case of
this application there were serious
doubts and concerns over whether three
of those tests have been met adequately
and indeed whether a proposal of 38
homes could ever be considered limited
when it's adjacent to the nearest
settlement development limit which
comprises just 27 homes uh the three
tests in question included whether
development was in keeping with the
character and Landscape of the nearest
settlement development limit area and
whether all plausible alternatives had
been adequately exhausted I think it's
worth pointing out that within a mile of
unen there are about 100 affordable
homes which are either in development
recently developed or with planning
permission perhaps the most important
test though was
lc3a which required the application to
demonstrate it was meeting a proven
local community need supported by an
upto-date local housing needs survey in
this case the survey was conducted uh
but only demonstrated a need for seven
properties not the 38 we which were put
forward uh as part of this application
how did we reconcile the difference well
a series of figures were then put
forward from our own housing strategy
team to try to demonstrate a higher
demand for affordable housing uh in unon
the problem with those figures was that
they were taken at face value and they
weren't subject uh to virtually any
scrutiny at all uh by the officer uh in
the officer report or sadly although
there were some at committee not as much
as should have been they included one
figure as an example for those on the
housing waiting list with a local
community connection to Wiston at being
505 people but when I dug into that with
the housing strategy teamed it turned
out that figure also included anyone
with a local connection to all of drumf
Cole Aon eckington renishaw marshlane
Ridgeway and barow on a population basis
hon only makes up about 5% of that wider
area so it's it's reasonable to assume
that that figure has basically been
inflated by 20 times uh to to what what
the actual realistic number would be for
unon and I'm extremely concerned that
the committee was given potentially
misleading figures to justify a
particular decision uh which may have
been non-compliant with with policy and
more to the point the policy wording is
very specific that only a local housing
needs survey can be relied upon it
doesn't go on to say if that figure
doesn't give you the figure that you
want if that survey doesn't give you the
figure that you want you can then go on
layer on additional information uh to
demonstrate a local uh need need I'm I'm
really concerned about the precedent
that this sets because effectively any
area that is desirable to live where
there a large number of bids for
properties for example on the housing
waiting list which is a lot of areas in
Northeast arire uh it it could
potentially mean that settlement
development limits don't mean anything
anymore a developer can come forward
with a s outside of the settlement
development limit potentially in the
green belt uh apply for planning
permission get the housing strategy team
to support them because essentially it's
their job to promote housing growth you
know that's that's their role so why
wouldn't they and you know Bob's your
uncle you've got a you got a planning
application approved um in this
particular case there were complaints
received and uh to be fair to the
officers to Lee and David I'm really
pleased that the council have stopped
short of issuing the decision notice and
you are investigating it you you sought
legal advice and I I really think that
for me demonstrates a really humble and
decent approach this is about checking
you know if we have made the wrong
decision or if there is any doubt over
the decision we should hold our hands up
you know take that time to review it and
and get to the bottom of it but that it
is an unusual step for committee to make
a decision and then the decision note is
not to be issued straight away we have
gone sort of beyond what we would
normally do here in going and getting
that additional advice and reconsidering
and I understand that process is still
ongoing but from my perspective from a
governance perspective it it should
surely have to go back to committee
whatever the outcome now that legal
advice might say well you're fine you're
okay you can make the you you know the
decision stands but in my P from my
perspective because it's gone outside of
the normal process that full advice and
the full office recommendations in light
of that advice ought to go back to the
committee so this application is really
asking for that application uh this
sorry this motion is really asking for
that application to go back to the
committee with that advice regardless of
what it says whether it says for or
against whatever I really think it's
important that the the committee get the
opportunity to consider it again and
residents also get the opportunity to
make those represent ations in light of
what the advice uh says I think it's
important that it's transparent and open
uh and and that's the that's the purpose
really behind this motion um so yeah as
I say that that's the that's the core
purpose behind it and I'm happy to move
it uh as it's written thank you chair
thank you councelor Dale do we have a
second councelor cupit you're wanting to
speak now I'll the right thank you right
so second by Council cupit any
comments Council Shipman thank you chair
um I am in support of this I don't know
all the ins and outs of the actual
application itself and I think that's
quite irrelevant to to what we're
debating here because as you'll remember
when I tried to do this same thing for
the clay Lane development which was to
get it looked at by planning the council
at the time refused to even send it back
to be looked at and I think that's a bad
position and way that this Council
should operate I think if something new
has come to light or we're concerned
about the way that a decision has been
made it makes perfect sense to send it
back to the planning committee just to
look at it may be that they arrive at
the exact same decision that they did in
the first place but time is crucial when
it comes to planning um decisions
because if they start the development it
then starts costing this Council more
money to if we do end up at the position
where you revoke that plan application
um so therefore I will be supporting
this motion I would also like to suggest
an amendment which is to add a third
point which is that standards look at a
mechanism to enable applications to be
reconsidered planning uh committee once
that decision's already been taken
because there's no mechanism that exists
other than it come to full Council for
us to approve to send it back to
planning it needs like a third of the
planning committee to be able to put it
on the agenda again or the chair can put
it on the agenda again but having them
come to full Council over time where
we've got 53 counselors to decide
whether it we even just look at a
decision again just seems insane to me
and I think we need to change the
standing orders to have that mechanism
in place so that would be my amendment I
don't know if the proposed in seconder
would accept that as a friendly one so
we don't have to debate and vote on it
but that's what I would do and I would
definitely support this motion just from
a practical point of view of looking at
our decisions again and and just double
checking that it is the correct one
thank you
CH I'm happy to take as a friendly
emotion on the basis that I think I
think it's legitimate we we ought to
have a process for um referring back
that doesn't involve full Council and
just to highlight I think on the clay
Lane application the challenge there was
that the development was already half
built and I think you're absolutely
right in this this scenario um is not
the case and actually in future
decisions if we had a quicker mechanism
uh by which to do this it would you know
necessitate having to wait for the next
full council meeting which could be
couple of months you know three months
if it happens during August it's it's
even longer obviously so just to to
Loose Ends have you a second for your
friendly Amendment
thank you and that's been accepted um as
a third point to the uh motion so the
standards to look at a mechanism to
um amend standing orders basically to uh
bring in
planning so yes please just to make sure
we've got the right
wording en
applications
okay so that's been accepted as a
friendly Amendment so we still
continuing to uh debate the original
motion as is Council
Pickering thank you um chair Ian all
I've got to say on this really is um you
know the motion to refer it back is a
bit like putting the carp before the
horse it's been to a committee material
considerations will have been taken into
account um you know it's been admitted
that things are now thrown into a
question um and it's going now through
due process uh we've taken external
advice um there'll be legal advice on
that and uh if um the advice that comes
back at the end of that due process is
that it needs to go back to planning
with some uh other things to be
considered then we wouldn't have any
objection to I mean that's the that's
the way it needs to go um but to
determine that before there's anything
new come to light um you know what's the
what's the point um so I think really we
need to get the the due process and the
um the inquiry uh and the investigation
complete we need to get the advice back
from that uh and then determine from
there why it will be going back to uh
planning committee and what the reasons
would be um as I said it's putting the
cart before the horse um it's preempting
any outcome or decision uh I can't
support this motion chair thank you
councel
Hancock thank you chair um obviously I
sit on planning committee and have done
for quite a long time so I'm not going
to debate the ins and outs of this it's
because that's the place the forum for
it um the key thing here um which I
think is picking up on the point Council
picking has just made there is no other
mechanism for doing it so we can't
really put a condition
um Motion in front of council here that
if we get legal advice back and if the
legal advice says this we will agree to
do this so I think um the spirit of the
motion that's that's here is that we
actually refer it back with that
external legal advice once it comes so I
think in order to facilitate it and stop
it costing the council an absolute small
fortune we need to move the to actually
pass this resolution today um because
obviously um as we know any unnecessary
delays in the planning system lead to
huge costs and uh and that that is a
something that we can't pass I think as
councilor Dale said earlier if it goes
back and the the decision is the same
then so be it but uh it's it's as Ross
has said earlier it's a failing in our
own standing orders our own Constitution
that we don't have any alternative
mechanism for doing this um so I'm I'm
fully supportive of the motion that's in
front of us thank you and Council
gillet if deal first of all with the
amendment what whatever the outcome of
the substantive motion I'm slightly
concerned about the amendment but the
undertaking I will give is that we are
reviewing the cons the Constitution as
we speak there's a meeting tomorrow
about it and we will raise it there
irrespective of what happens here so
that we can actually look into it and
have some proper advice and determine
whether that is an appropriate thing to
do because I am slightly worried that
we're about to turn the full Council
into an appellant body for planning
matters and that does indeed worry me
because planning is a crazy judicial
function that has to follow set rules
now this all seems to me to be about
process and whether we're following the
right process or not and councelor Dale
quite rightly and I understand why I did
it he asked a question earlier about
process and then um had some criticisms
about whether the process was duly
followed and now we've been asked to
adopt something completely different but
the answer to that question that you
asked councel Dale was um in terms of um
should proper National local and
national and local planning policies be
followed it's a clear yes nobody in this
room would say anything otherwise and
you knew that before you you asked the
question um but the need to comply with
national and local planning policies is
one of the reasons we have a planning
committee where we have members of this
Authority who are trained in that who
have proper office advice both legal and
planning before they make a decisions to
try and ensure that they do take
decisions that are considered to be
consistent with local and National
planning policies well I'm been asked to
take a planning decision today in many
respects but I'm not a matter of the
planning committee and never have been I
have no planning training I don't claim
to be familiar with the case or with
local or national uh planning policies
that are pertinent to this application
I've received no office of advice or
guidance on this case I haven't read any
report to deal with it or I can't claim
to fully understand all the issues
involved I'm not familiar with the
arguments for or against it all I only
know is what councilor Dale has told us
today both over and in his motion nor do
I profess to understand the planning
consequences of the decision I'm being
invited to take
today but but perhaps perhaps
counselor will have the courtesy to let
me finish because I think this is what
I'm saying this is about process and I'm
being asked to take a decision to refer
something back to a planning committee
that is a process and I don't think this
is the right process to go through for
making that decision
so as I say councelor Dale has told us
that we've had some external legal
advice I don't know what that advice is
but I accept it's being sought it could
be about proes it could be about
judicial review or it could be about the
merits of the application I simply don't
know nobody's told me what the actual
issue is it sounds like it's judicial
review rather than about the process of
the application the M of the application
but I don't know and we haven't received
that
advice what I do know and I should say
you know that that doesn't apply to me
but what I do know is I'm not the only
person in that position today there's
lots of members of this Council who are
in exactly that same position and yet as
I say we''re been asked to refer this
back to planning without understanding
whether that's the right thing to do
both legally and in terms of planning
conditions the one thing I do know is
that both councelor Pickering and
counselor Hartson as a chair of the
planning committee if they receive
professional advice from the head of
planning and the director of legal
services to refer this matter back I
have no doubt whatsoever that they will
do that and in that sense there is
already a process for doing it um and
the process is that when we get a
complaint that suggests we're not doing
that it goes to those people and to the
planning officers and the head of legal
and they will give the appropriate
advice so I think there is a mechanism
for doing it but I accept it might not
be the best mechanism which is why I
said we will undertake it take it away
and have a a proper review of it I also
want to pick up what councelor Shipman
said about clay Lane because that's
always at the back of my mind it comes
to planning as well and and that was a
case where that there was strong local
opposition from the residents there was
strong local opposition from the local
members and the members some members of
the plan committee spoke out against it
and they continued to speak out against
it even when it came to light that there
might have been a fact
advice don't forget I was interrupted
though chair a facted that in it's like
football there so it is it is n minutes
of extra time so we've been asked to
give it wait to to that chair but so for
those reasons we're being asked to
follow process at the planning meeting I
don't think we're following it today I
as I said I'm more than happy to take
away and look at the process and see
whether there is a better process on
this but I can't vote for it today until
unless until somebody tells me that this
process that we're being invited to
adopt today is both legally and in
planning terms the correct process thank
you Council jillet H just to be clear
about the amendment it was subsumed as a
friendly Amendment into this motion so
there isn't a conversation to vote on an
amendment and then this this is the
substantive motion that we're actually
discussing it's uh planning is not a
quasi judicial committee licensing is
planning isn't and I know that's the
second time in a few months that Council
Jill has actually said that thank you
any other comments or
questions right we are going to vote on
motion B and just to point out there is
that third
oh before yes so we've got councelor cup
it but I just want to be clear when we
do come to vote there is now a third
Point added which is about standards
committee looking at a mechanism to
enable recall for planning application
so that will be in so Council
cupit D Council
Dale thank you J just try and cover off
some of the points that have been made
um cancel Pickering said that material
considerations were taken into account I
think the whole point of this is that
there was some errors in the information
or there was certainly some misleading
information that wasn't picked up so you
have a case where material
considerations may have been taken into
account which were not true and I think
that is really quite worrying from my
perspective you've got a situation where
we've made a decision on the basis of
one set of information which the rug may
be being pulled from under us uh the
legal the points about legal advice
um from my perspective and and Mrs
Sternberg please close your ears because
this is no criticism but legal advice is
very very rarely clearcut it's never
black or white there is a range of views
considerations a balance to be struck so
there there's quite it's quite possible
that the legal advice will come back and
say well you you might be okay but there
is a bit of a risk here now for me it's
officers that have taken that decision
to go and get that legal advice as far
as planning committee officially knows
they don't even know that's happened
it's not been reported to them in any
way as far as I can see officers have
taken a a decision and rightly so in my
my opinion outside of the usual process
and gone and got legal advice now
whatever that legal advice should be has
to go back to committee from from my
perspective because that's proper
governance that's what councils are
supposed to do we we have a governance
process it's we as elected members that
make decisions and and something unusual
has happened here and whatever that
legal advice may be it probably won't be
complet completely clearcut there'll be
a balance to be struck so it has to go
back to committee and all this this is
seeking to do I I really struggled to be
H this with counselor gillet's mental
gymnastics on this because we were
talking about process and then we
weren't talking about process and I mean
this this is outside of the usual
process it's subject to Legal challenge
whatever we do uh we're not being asked
to make a planning decision we're asking
to send it back to planning committee
with advice that we've sought externally
with investigations that and it's not
just legal advice they were actually as
I understand it officers are also
reviewing the housing strategy officer
information that was supplied to try and
make sure that that was correct so there
not just legal advice we're asking all
of that bundle of information to go back
to planning committee so they can decide
whether they made the right decision
originally or not and have have another
opportunity to to change it and I don't
think we should wait for the legal
advice to decide that I think we should
make the commitment that we will do that
come what may because that's the
appropriate thing to do in a situation
where we've gone outside of the usual
process
uh so yeah I'm happy to move to the vote
sh thank you thank you so we will move
to the vote so some that on the screen
please
okay hopefully you made your final
decision show the results
please so the motion is
lost motion C then proposed by councelor
adlington
Stringer
thank you
chair the last motion which I brought to
council was considered by some of you to
be highly controversial and whilst the
ceasefire in gazer is still urgently
needed this month I'm taking on a
challenge known to parents across the
world I'm asking you to eat your
greens my first job was on a butcher
counter in Morrison Supermarket Making
burgers and mopping up blood was perhaps
surprisingly once a normal part of my
day-to-day routine my plant-based
Journey began at the same time I start
to engage with politics and social
issues I started to question the World
by first considering my own personal
actions we welcome in the new year as
2023 was declared the hottest year on
record the devastating impact of
flooding in our area is all to real
reminder of such reflecting as we do at
the start of each year reminds us that
it's now five years since this Council
declared a climate
emergency whilst many positive changes
have been made and I thank you for those
there still remain many small winds that
are yet to be taken full advantage
of I know that this Council which has
demonstrated its commit commitment to
protecting our environment by initiating
the first ever environment scrutiny
committee will be Keen to adopt these
changes the switch to plant-based
catering is a simple step that this
Council can take to tackle the climate
crisis and promote healthier eating
choices Nation wide animal agriculture
is responsible for 47% of the UK's
methane emissions and 68% of our nitrous
oxide emissions the problem is reflected
here in Northeast darbishire 2 the
council's own report states that 0.9% of
Northeast darish emissions are from
agriculture whil it's a huge 6.9% that's
nearly 7% of our emissions are from
livestock the cost of rearing animals
for consumption is one of the leading
causes of emissions in our area
researchers at Oxford University found
that vegan plant-based diets resulted in
a
75% less climate heating emissions water
pollution and land use than diets which
included 100 grams of meat each day 100
grams of meat each day is four wafer
thin slices of beef about2 30 from Tesco
I
checked some of you may be thinking that
increasing soy production is responsible
for Rapid deforestation and yes you are
right 77% of that soy however is used to
feed livestock in fact more soy is used
for biodiesel production than the 2.6%
required for the world's
tofu so what about organic Freer range
meat deforestation for the soy which
feeds our Livestock pales in comparison
to the land used to graze our animals
the meat with the lowest impact is
organic pork but that is still
responsible for eight times more climate
change than the highest impact plants
which are seed oils half of the world's
habitable land is used for agriculture
with most of this use to raise life
stock and dairy in England alone a
whopping 68% of the total land mass is
used for
agriculture if everyone shifted to a
plant-based diet we would reduce Global
land use for agriculture by
75% that is because it takes a 100 times
more land to produce a kilogram of
protein from beef or lamp than it does
from peas or tofu only 6% of the UK is
urbanized meaning that eating more
plants creates a solution to the climate
crisis to the housing crisis whilst also
allowing native species to thrive it's
beyond doubt that a plant-based diet
will reduce emissions clean up our
waterways increase biodiversity ease the
housing crisis and stop suffering for
animals or while providing you with just
as much if not more nutritional value
yet the reduced reuse recycle rethink
climate change strategy of the previous
Council Administration does not mention
the words vegan vegetarian food diet or
Farms once
we must show leadership as a council and
Empower our residents whether they are
farmers or consumers to make climate
friendly choices I hope that as we
embark on 2024 we are able to support
local farmers in transitioning with us
for years the heroes that feed us have
been thrown to one side and squeezed out
by big business it's time that we reward
the custodians of our land for their
hard work in feeding our nation by
ensuring that they are future ready and
able to capitalize sustainably on the
future Food Market let's make your
parents proud and start this pee eating
journey together as a community who
knows your taste buds might enjoy the
ride too thank you very much thank you
do we have a second there Council
weather all do you wish to speak now can
I reserve certainly so councelor Barker
yeah thanks Frank and and it's good that
you only sub submit uncontentious
motions
pleas please please to have
you just just last May though that we
went against conventions and uh and gave
you a role as the vice chair scrutiny
committee uh and we did that with the
belief that opposition members would
take it seriously and act responsibly
and use that opportunity to give to
raise concerns like these at their
meetings uh and
hopefully uh not just score political
points uh and we specifically ask you to
be the vice chair of environment
committee that were no accident with
your background and and and the speech
you've just made which were very good uh
you didn't convince me though uh turning
to the motion itself I can't support it
as it currently stands I made clear that
before that the council and it's now
part of the Constitution that we do not
consider motions that commit this
Council to a change in policy or or
which spend money without without the
proposal going through due process which
includes proper officer advice and it's
not a responsible way to act him when
spending taxpayers money I know from a
brief discussion with officers that the
motion you propos is not a
straightforward matter and there some
complexities complexities that might not
be obvious at First Sight they tell me
that it will involve choices being made
if the council were to go down this
route and that it has financial
implications for Northeast arish having
said that it doesn't necessarily mean
I'm saying we shouldn't adopt it this
policy it just means that we should take
our responsibility seriously and only
make decisions after dual process and
full consideration of all the relevant
facts and issues with that in mind I
would like to suggest one or two courses
either that you withdraw the motion in
the knowledge that my group will support
support you if you went to took it to
the environment scrutiny committee to
conduct a review Into the proposals you
rais and I if that's not acceptable I
would ask that you accept an amendment
to the motion to the effect that Council
refers the motion to the environment
scrutiny committee for consideration and
that the committee then submit a report
to Cabinet detailing the outcome of
those
deliberations I hope you think that's a
Fair Way Forward and I know you're
passionate about about your stuff Frank
it's it's good and I accept that you may
want a quick word with your seconded to
decide how to proceed if however you're
willing to accept either of dues C of
action I want to proceed to a vote on
the motion as printed and I my group
would have no choice but to vote against
the
motion that's right dragon's dend you
want to go to the
wall Y El Addington
Stringer yeah I'm happy for it to go to
scrutiny it's a um a decision which uh I
was able to take overnight before uh and
it saved me money and wasn't very
complex at all uh just required a
shopping list but for as this Council
scene we can throw things backwards and
forwards we'll go through scrutiny if
that's way we have to do it that's the
way we do it are you withdrawing the
motion or are you wanting it added I'm
wanting it added as an amendment right
so we're adding now to a
four considered screw to
me okay so added coun
Dale
yeah thank you chair it won't surprise
counc rington Springer to know that I
can't support the motion um two main
reasons and and I will just just start
by saying that actually from a health
perspective I had started to today just
we've
got can we just have one meeting please
Council D today for example I'm on a
fully vegetarian diet I'm yeah taking
some bold steps actually from having
looked into it a bit more from a health
perspective I've not completely
eliminated meat yet uh and don't intend
to but you know I'm trying to cut down
for for various different reasons I
think that's you know that's each to our
own um I even tried tofu the other day
which was an experience um I invite for
looking forward to it yeah sounds good
um the two two main reasons for me are I
think really I'm I'm pro-choice I don't
really agree with the council uh
influencing what people want to eat uh
in this way you know this is about us
all making an informed choice and would
would sort of support some of what you
say in terms of people looking at what's
out there in terms of the information uh
but I think that that's incumbent upon
all of us to do that and I think the
second point is you know you mentioned
Farmers but times are tough for farmers
and diversification is not easy and
fundamentally we're you know we're a
rural District we've got um we've got
you know countless Farmers across the
district who uh who do a very good job
and and animal standards in this country
are very good and you know I think I
want to really praise the work that our
farming Community do uh in rearing good
good meat and good um Dairy produce uh
and you know I think it's slightly
surprising that the motion has been
seconded by someone and K the weather
all who you know represents the largest
farming community so looking forward to
hearing what what what she has to say so
yeah while I complet can't can't
completely disagree with everything that
councelor adlington Stringer has said I
can't support the motion because I just
don't think this is the of a council and
I don't think we can uh go against our
farming community in in such a wayk you
Council
Welton yeah comes on great okay um I
agree with all the comments that was
made by councelor Dale I think this is
coercive it's authoritarian we should
have the right to respect each other's
Lifestyles I've worked uh and known many
very strict vegans particularly when I
was living in Asia Buddhists Jes um
Hindus fully respect the ability to have
to live the life they want that should
also be reciprocated as well just coming
on to the hard I'm going to talk about
hard pasture and cheese an unintended
consequence of this would be the Banning
of stil and cheese we one of the four
counties leester sorry lestershire
Rutland although it doesn't exist
anymore not inure and darbishire that
can make Stilton so the Hartington crey
with our tourist office we could have
Stilton cheese or bakel pudding or tart
personally I prefer buckton pudding but
that's a personal choice so buckon so
bake the bake W shop the bake W pudding
will be banned hard pasture and it's a
response to all this stuff about grain
you will notice that we have place names
like t mtor means mother mother Hill or
more um D Moore grass Moore because our
geology is Hills and that's why we have
a predominantly pasture based Farmers
some of them have a hard time hard
pasture mainly lamb but you'll also see
deer you'll see some beef quite rare to
get the beef you'll see the Highland
cattle as you go through the Peak
District park they eat grass they don't
have any antibiotics they don't have any
hormones um and they eat what on on land
that you cannot have agriculture in
terms of growing plants so I think this
motion doesn't understand the history
daisher means deer hunting ground in
Anglo Saxon it do understand the
geography or the economy I've got farms
in dronfield uh I've got Organic Farms
geese um beef sheep and it doesn't
understand the culture we still have
people here who obtain their own protein
rabbit rabbits Trap Fishing and I think
we should respect that right that's part
that's part of darbishire it's part of
our history and and culture but I
respect other people who want to be
vegan and I completely respect that
thank
you Council
windley thank you chair yeah I'm not
comfortable with this at all um the
first one I'm not too sure if it means
that only plant-based foods should be um
provided at Council
meetings which I don't agree with that
and it's a bit like the others I'll cut
it short because others have said very
similar to what I was going to say it's
a bit dictating and there are some
people we need to remember that do have
certain conditions that can't eat a lot
of plant-based Foods unfortunately even
though they would prefer that way so we
we just need to be mindful that it's a
bit dictating this so yeah to promote it
you know leaflets and things on walls
but not to push it down people's throats
I'm sorry not literally anyway
no council Reed yeah yet do I have to
press something it's red okay it's there
no it's good um look I I uh I will agree
with Frank on this I I think that we
should be where possible under our
responsibility promoting healthy
lifestyle to people and and giving them
choice where I have a challenge is where
we I'll start with point three where
we're promoting plant-based and reducing
advertising for other things what part
of this goes into um the health
provision uh the NHS provides the gu
lines for what a good diet is and I
don't know if that's the responsibility
of District Council or local Council or
where it is I'm happy to support that
but not at the expense of something else
and I don't think that council is a
health providing body I think that that
should be left to the medical
professionals do I think we should have
choice in our Ledger centers and things
like that sure but that is a personal
preference um again the economic
concerns that have been raised are great
and we've just gone through talking
about the budget and raising certain
things what I'm really concerned about
there is the impact on local businesses
I believe a motion similar to this
passed down brighten way um through the
council and it got quickly overturned by
the unions and so they had to reverse
the decision I'm all for it going to uh
scrutiny committee and being looked at
but I think there are some very serious
implications that on face value this
doesn't address um and I don't think
that in this form it without a very
significant change I could support it
and like others have have echoed we live
in a democracy and it has to be personal
choice I'm all for putting something out
to educate people and letting them
choose but we can't as a council local
or District or otherwise dictate to
people how they should live their lives
and I don't think that's the spirit with
which this is intended and I understand
it's all about trying to promote and to
safeguard our our planet for people in
future Generations however I want to be
very careful to get the balance right
that we're not overstepping what our
Authority is as representatives and
telling people how they should live
thank you Council
Hancock thank you chair yeah I mean I'm
going to pick up on that the
authoritarianism in this is horrendous
I'm fully support the motion if it is
about promoting and adding extra Choice
um I think that that's a wonderful thing
to do if you can encourage people to
change what they eat because they choose
to do so that's fine but to actually say
no you can't have this you can't have
that that to me is is not an acceptable
an acceptable position for us to take so
I can't support it I'm afraid Council
gillet the amendment to the motion I
think changes the motion slightly from
asking Council to do this but by
referring it to scrutiny it's asking
Council to consider it and as Council
Barker said there are lots of
complexities to this many of which have
come out today and like other people
have said if this was pushed to a vote
today without that amendment I think I
would have voted against it but I have
no difficulty whatsoever in a proper
debate taking place at a scotin new
committee meeting it may be that we
decide not to do this in full but it
could be as a result of this there are
things that we do decide to do and I
think they should be properly examined
with recommendations coming back to
cabinet so on that basis chair I'm I'm
happy to support it since it is simply
going to scooting the committee for a
proper investigation with and hopefully
some constructive recommendations coming
out of it but I suspect it won't be 100%
with what this particular motion was
originally asking for thank you Council
Shipman thank you chair
um before the labor amendment I was
actually going to amend it myself um
particularly removing 01 because I I I I
believe in choice I would have changed
the word prioritizing to promote and add
in after plant-based and all vegan um
vegetarian acceptable options
because like I don't know one of the
councelor mentioned it about the um in
terms of what people can eat and their
their health reasons for eating certain
foods I think if you're just shoving it
down people's throats that you've got to
be plant-based you're not going to get
the buying from Resident you've got to
kind of lead a horse to water and and
and you know gradually get to a point
you can't just expect everyone to wake
up tomorrow and everyone be vegan
because that's just you know Pie in the
Sky stuff you're not going to convince
people that way um so I don't know if
it's worth me amending it so that
scrutiny are considering a different
proposal because the current proposal
would certainly not be happy with
scrutiny considering it as it's written
now so what's the motion looking like
now before I decide whether to amend it
or
not well the the amendment is about this
all going to to a scrutiny to be
considered but I'll just let Council B
could clarify yeah just just to clarify
in my head I'm just looking at the
motion and it it's it cross commits too
and then it's uh to to consider the
following issu issues as they as they
written the one two three consider those
uh three issues uh through an
environment scrutiny committee does that
make sense so so it's as written but
instead of committing the council to it
all we're committing to is that it goes
to the but but to leave those in as
written and and consider the one the
pros and cons of them issues yeah so
that they take it's taking out a very
key bit there about commits to so it's
all of these matters will then be taken
to a scrutiny committee for
consideration so all of these things
outlined in here will form part of a
discussion at scrutiny yeah does that
help you kind of but I just make it
clear no I haven't given you
notification to speak yet just just wait
one like I say personally I would I
wouldn't like to see the scrutiny
debating with u point one and I would
the last bit of point three where it
says on removal of meat and dairy ADT
iing and the where it says prioritizing
I would change that to promot and then
after plant-based I would say and other
veget vegetarian acceptable options
because I don't want the committee to be
do something that I completely disagree
with isn't committing to anything it's a
discussion but I'm going to let Council
alington string answer to that point
okay I
AC
yes I I accept the amendment as a
friendly Mo Amendment and therefore I'm
assuming we don't need to have a vote on
the amendment so the proposal is there
as it is but we will have that
discussion in scrutiny it's not going to
be up going to per this isn't my right
of reply um but authoritarian Frank
isn't going to dominate it there will be
a selection of counselors in the room
and we will have a conversation uh just
remind you I'm the only green you might
try and silence them though it be a
debate at scrutiny that's it's not
committing to anything today it's for
scrutiny that's that's where it end
up any other
comments if not I'm going to come back
to council weather all for her right to
reply as a
seconder yes thank you thank you chair
very happy with the amendment I think it
moves things forward whatever comes out
of that I think the discussions will be
useful just the point around ashover
Farmers just talking to ashover Farmers
they are getting rid of their herds of
cattle because they cannot afford to
keep them going the small family farm in
ashover are diversifying enormously
doing all sorts of things including
Holiday Homes and all sorts of things
because they cannot afford the cattle
feed Dairy herds are uh being not
destroyed but are being uh dismantled um
and and um so I think this is a
direction of travel and I think it's
about demonstrating leadership in a at a
time when climate change is absolutely
hitting us around the head um daily so I
wanted to thank Council adlington
Stringer for bringing this forward I'm
worried about climate change and the
implications for us all particularly for
my
grandchildren last year as Frank said
hottest year on record this year maybe
even hotter hot air means uh more
extreme weather events more absorption
of water more um rain more flooding the
economic and human costs of that
enormous and I think our response has to
be twofold first of all big commitments
like um uh reducing oil and gas
extraction but then in addition to that
a myriad of small changes councelor Dale
I admire you for for what for doing that
and I I want to know how you're getting
on because I need to do that um I need
to ask um councelor Barker whether he
still loses dripping in his chip Pan um
I've got I knew you
did don't
fall um I guess that was the case but
Myriad of small changes at personal
family and organization level and I
think this motion supports that approach
um this this this um demonstration of
our commitment um and and maybe um not
um enforcing it but actually encouraging
it strongly encouraging it so that we
are on that direction of travel um so
I'm happy with the amendment I'm happy
with the discussion we've had and want
to thank uh thank the council for for
listening thank you counc lington string
your final
response well of course he going through
without a
vote dictator um I just want to pick up
a couple of points there um there's a
lot of conversation about pro-choice yes
people can eat whatever they want to eat
at home this is is about us as a
leadership organization that's our role
and I have to remind you of that it's
quite scary we we are leading our
communities we are showing the way we
are treading the path so they can follow
and they can make similar choices if
they choose to at home and personal
preference aside they make their choices
and my personal preference is that I
have a future that my children have a
future my grandchildren have a future
and if that means eating a few less
Burgers along the way then I'm happy to
do that and that's for other people to
make their choice as well but we as a
council should lead the way based on
science based on facts in front of
us um we don't have food at Council
meetings so you know we go hungry anyway
um just to address w councelor windle's
point um the Bell tart shop uh I've
actually bought a vegan bakel tart from
there
before so we're about progress about
changing about making options providing
for people leading the way the b t shop
they're ahead of the game mate
the same goes for Stilton and the same
goes for a range of other things we're
finding Alternatives we're finding ways
we're adapting to The Climate which has
been so long forgotten about and which
has been put behind profit for all too
long we want to support farmers and
councelor Dale I come back to your point
as I so often have to um you're happy to
let consumers bring down the dairy meat
and dairy industry you're happy for them
to make choices at home but you're not
happy for us to be ahead of the game to
put the steps in place to try and create
a smooth transition to the way the
world's going to create a sustainable
future that is putting farmers at risk
that is leaving people in ashover people
across our district in rawal part of the
world in economic uncertainty and we
should be taking a lead on that so I
feel that's an absolute failure of this
Council and to just the the rhetoric
just want to finish the the some of the
the the discourse used in this room has
been absolutely appalling I'm someone
concerned about climate someone who
wants to see our Council taking steps in
the right direction and for you to sit
here here and call me authoritarian
dictatorial um and and to suggest that
this is this is some kind of power play
is is ridiculous this is a democracy and
we come in here to debate things
sensibly and as far as I can see you all
agree with doing it Council Dale wants
to do it one day a week people want to
make these changes let's take a bold
step and lead the way and stop hiding
behind reviews thank you very
much so just to be clear then the
friendly amendment was agreed which was
that we're taking out the word about
commits to but we are asking that it's
consider these matters are considered as
a scrutiny committee so let's move to
the
vote
right you're not off for s's
role right I think we've had enough time
to vote so let's go to the
results that's it the motion is
carried thank you so item 12 there's no
urgent business for myself so we move to
item 13 I'm move that the public be
excluded from the meeting during the
discussion of the following items of
business to avoid the disclosure to them
of exempt information is defined in
paragraphs 1 2 3 4 and five part one of
schedule 128 of the Local Government Act
1972 as amended by the local government
access to information variation order
2006 can I have a second please thank
you all those in
favor thank you that's carried so we're
going to move into exclusion of public
um so we need to switch off off the uh
live
streaming is it right thank you I can
confirm that live streaming has ended so
we moveed to item 14 the Derby and
darbishire strategic leadership board
over to you Council
Barker thank you yeah
that strategic leadership board
brilliant uh and I'm sure you've all it
this report it's
uh it's got all the information you need
but to cut a long story short I think
this board is designed to replace three
other
committees uh that have been for quite a
while uh and I know Lee when I got to
bit lead there